what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel make sure you
like the video on your way in today we
got a special guest on the channel
welcome to just pearly things MLD thank
you thank you clap for myself glad to be
back glad to be back tell the people
about yourself about about your channel
uh my name is MLD I run a men's
self-improvement Channel and what I'm
doing is I'm just helping guys uh level
up you know if you ever hear this the
saying money muscles game frame that
comes from me I'm just always talking to
guys and telling them do better level up
just do better because a lot of guys
nowadays are just you know lost taking
the path of mediocrity and it's uh
messing everything up I think you know
Pearl you're telling girls get to get
their crap together I'm telling guys to
get their stuff together that's what I
do I have a YouTube channel you can find
me Modern Life dating I do live streams
there daily and yeah ready to do this
tape breakdown with you yeah so um today
we're going to be doing part two but we
had so all right we had such a lively
discussion yesterday
you know we had some
we could say fan favorites or most hated
on the channel so it was tough to get
through the Tate video but yeah I
decided tonight we could uh finish it
but before we start um there is some
Tate updates in the case so
um today let me find it one second
update on the tape case the Tate
brothers were not charged today today
the D2 cot has rearranged the files they
have um changed the charges to try and
charge the tapes with really weak and
insufficient evidence why do you think
they're trying to charge them so bad
well so I heard so the the head of dicot
is this new woman she's like the chief
prosecutor of course and I heard she's
trying to make her name off of
putting tape Behind Bars oh that's what
I heard I heard she's out there trying
to like make a name for herself so you
know when you have the most Googled man
in the world and he could be a you know
theoretical criminal in your justice
system to lock him up it's gonna look
really good on your resume and you know
most people are out to climb that
corporate ladder you know when you have
a clout all the worms come out from the
the you know the the trenches and try to
pull you down in order to lift
themselves up so I don't know like this
whole the situation with the details of
the case only the Tates understand the
details but I do know that this is a
woman that is like trying to make a name
for herself of course women being
emotional yeah I know if she had a
husband that she respected this wouldn't
be happening
producing say hi King
how do the people in the chat hello
um okay let's let me pull up the chat
also guys super chats we're gonna try to
do super chats every like 20 minutes so
if you have something you you want to
ask or question whatever it is statement
we will I will be checking the chat so
we're gonna do like a watch party
um and how many likes to open up the
chat today
1500 a thousand five hundred likes and
we'll open up the chat all right that's
do you wanna um can you do it where
we're small and it's big
I really blessing was doing it yesterday
maybe just ask him when he gets back
okay
um
yeah if you can make it a little bigger
also guys if you want to see part one go
to the video from yesterday
okay a little smaller I'm sorry a little
smaller there we go perfect just a
little down and then it'll be good
and I'm trying to play it but I can't
click that yeah that's good
sorry guys in the chat like the video
while you're waiting please like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these live
streams so make sure you hit the like
button so they try and find an attack
vector and what happens when you have
somebody who's monumentally successful
across all Realms of human endeavor the
only way you can attack them is by
calling them a bad person they can't
call me stupid they can't call me ugly
can't call me bro can't call me weak
they can't go any of these things so how
do you attack this guy well he's a bad
person how do you call someone a bad
person you weaponize virtue none of the
people not who are pretending to give a
about women
and that I'm bad to protect women have
any interest in protecting women none of
these people think I better become
physically strong so protect women none
of them even believe in protecting a
woman in a physical scenario let them
even believe in protecting their family
none of them have any none of them
donate to any Charities that involve
women nothing they're just taking the
virtue and weaponizing it and attacking
me with it me as a person who donates to
25 million dollars a year to charity to
feed both male and female children me as
a person who believes I have a
responsibility to be physically capable
so that any woman I'm walking down the
street with is safe I do more for women
than any of these clowns would ever do
but they're just weaponizing virtue and
attacking me with this not even genuine
virtue that's what's so upsetting that's
always the people that are doing nothing
and I want to criticize the people that
are doing something it's like none of
these and that's the thing none of these
guys that hate take care about women
because all they do is they tell us what
we want to hear they simp and that
doesn't help us it might sound good it
might make them look good but saying oh
we don't mind girls that are old we
don't mind girls that are hoes we don't
mind girls that are overweight
um men should have like low standards
that doesn't help us because it's not
realistic because the men we want have
standards yeah I mean I just think that
they're just trying to I mean dude the
the CTR on those videos is through the
roof like you know the liberal videos
the the pro everything agendas and when
when you just look at the root of the
cause of these people and what they're
saying they're only just everything
they're doing is lies and manipulation
for money that's all it is they don't
really believe this but they're out
there lying and deceiving the masses
because they don't give a all they
care about is getting paid that's bottom
line these people the matrix-minded
people have so few parameters and so few
virtue whenever there's virtue inside of
them it's only so they can take it
weaponize it and fire at you they don't
give a about any of the issues they
talk about they don't care about race
They Don't Care About Women they don't
care about gays none of it they take it
they put it in a bullet and they shoot
at the people they don't like it's all
fake yeah all of it it's all fake when
you were talking about this
um I wrote all these things down that
we're talking about principles when that
when all the when all the freaking
Fuentes stuff happened to me and that
was the most annoying part was I know
these people behind the scenes and I'm
like they are not offended
oh yeah are you talking about it uh the
reaction like reaction Channel like yeah
yeah like the guys who like like and I'm
like and that's that's what he's talking
about is it's fake outrage like do you
guys think and you guys have to think
about this do you guys think grown men
like grown adult it's one thing like
when you're young you get mad over dumb
stuff you know your hormones are rage
and but okay men and women over 30. are
they really outraged about sexism are
they really outraged about racism are
they really outraged genuinely I don't
living in the west no it's fake it's
performative my thing is this too I
think that these people who are pseudo
outrage I feel like they're doing that
to compensate for some like dirty
real dirty skeletons in their
closet that's the crazy thing is it's
like the people that that are pointing
fingers that everybody always have so
much crazy stuff but it's like our side
doesn't go that low usually so we won't
like put anything out there but it's
it's so annoying
virtues God Parents True Believers
Fighters Traditions these people they
fear right all these people they fear
and these guys are slowly but surely
starting to stand up the scene we're
talking about with Shia LaBeouf he says
what we're doing here is a righteous act
here's a Bible verse I think about
sometimes many times this is his words
it goes and I heard the voice of the
Lord saying whom shall I send and who
will go for us and event began crying
and said here I am send me Brad Pitt
turns around and says book of Isaiah
chapter 6.
for me
in my own business I asked this question
the other day I'm so curious to get your
thoughts on this for the longest time
when I got into business I was you know
a younger guy 21 I'm like okay very
coachable tell me what I got to do I'm a
coachable guy what I got to do I'm a
coachable guy super coach won't want to
make money I'm second time being broke
my dad's at the 99 cent store too many
heart attacks I want to get out of this
yeah so I'm like hey Patrick basic stuff
when you're doing business and you're
talking to rich people at Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter never talk religion never
talk politics never talk sex just don't
talk about those three things I said
okay guess what never talk politics
never talk religion never talk sex no
problem we're going to business so what
do you think about the political climate
today Patrick David oh what do you think
yeah you know well I think this is but
what do you think Patrick I don't know
you know quite frankly I think I'm
trying to figure it out for myself right
now but we'll see what's going to happen
like you know the whatever way you're
deflecting and you're kind of go on your
phone hey what do you think about God
what is your opinion on Islam or Muslim
well you know for me you know there's
you deflect but eventually you're
sitting there you're like
the people that I know at that level
want to talk about those three topics
now sex is maybe off camera and they're
kind of having fun with it yeah but they
want to talk about politics and religion
yeah so we for the longest time have
been silenced and now the ESG community
all this time they've told us to stay
quiet and they're saying what they're
talking politics yeah they're talking
religion and they're talking sex the way
through lgbtq what's wrong with that
what's wrong with it's normal it's
normal it's normal no it's not normal
well listen you guys shouldn't talk
about politics and sex and religion you
shouldn't be doing that yeah and then
you see this one you know during covet
One Pastor Australia Syrian man I don't
know what his name is Vinnie what's his
name the Syrian Pastor priest from
Australia and he was fighting all the
anti-covet guidelines and he's his stuff
is going viral he's doing this and
you've seen these messages some of the
people that stood up they stood up
because they feared God okay and for you
with your life it's been interesting
watching you go through your evolution
of your faith
pre-2022 former atheist couple of the
things you've said in the past God isn't
wait he was an atheist in 2022 yeah I
think he was wow that's so recent yeah
wow a year ago yeah the way like the way
he talks I just thought I thought it
would have been so much longer I mean
he's on record saying like he likes
being in in places that have God he was
on the full send podcast and you know we
share the same uh perspective on Miami
like when you go to Miami can you like
feel the grime
I feel it the most in California
actually L.A yeah yeah LA's a
it is like I go there too no I I feel
the grime I remember I felt it because I
was in LA like 2019 and I might be back
there for the no jumper in like a couple
weeks but uh L.A and then like Miami
Miami just is like such a like grimy
sexually fueled like sexually
transaction kind of city that I just uh
I don't know I can't I can't deal with
it so he was saying that he doesn't like
being those kind of places either
because what is it it's like drugs and
like what is Miami right Bitcoin
again a little bit but mainly drugs
right so being around those kind
of things it's just not good for you he
says he likes being around churches
Cathedrals places where there's religion
that's what he said I love being by my
parents house and because it's actually
it's by Chicago but it's so far out that
I just love being in like family
neighborhoods where there's all this
space the grass is green they have the
white picket fences uh I mean we have a
bit more land by like where we're at but
it's it's just like nice yeah it's
there's I live by um a retirement
neighbor I love old people yeah they're
like they're so much more based yeah
because they're they're not like
mentally weak like all the Zoomers and
people who grew up on Tick Tock yeah
real because you can't prove it okay
kind of like uh that was more the
Malcolm X argument right bad things
happen to good people and good things
happen to bad people far too often for
God to exist yep I'm the Center of My
Universe that's pre-2020 then gradually
you start talking huh keep passing that
I'm sorry I can't reach it yeah you know
2020 made a video announcing that you
were wrong about what you had said
previously about God right now you start
saying people are who are atheists are
angry bad energy people and I don't want
to be on that team anymore and even if
God is not real the world is a better
place if people do believe in God I
agree because there's so much evil in
the world that there has to be an equal
and opposite Force let me ask you
something so you grew up in church right
Catholic yeah I grew up in the
Pentecostal church I I honestly I value
the fact that I grew up in church
because I feel like it gave me a good
sense of morality and a good sense of
you know just being a decent just human
being and like even if you do something
bad like at least you feel guilt or
shame for it you know no I I actually I
love being Catholic you know I wouldn't
say I feel bad because I I feel like I'm
not a good kid like there's so many
better like Catholics than me but but
um why are you a bad Catholic do you
drink no no you smoke no not really not
they're fornicating not
really but it's like so then what are
you bad Catholic I mean I don't to
church as much as I should like I feel
like I should I should go to church like
every Sunday and like uh but I'm
actually I'm decided that's one of my
goals this year I want to go more so I'm
trying to move I'm moving my Saturday
shows to Friday so I could go more but
okay but I actually do you know what I
like about Catholicism and people think
this is weird Okay but that we have
confession yeah no because it's like
imagine it's like a coach every week to
be a good person like because I feel
like saying your sins out loud makes
them like real yeah and you confess like
you know confronting your shittiness
yeah and so every week you gotta go tell
a priest what you did what you feel bad
about yeah and it's one it's very
freeing and two it's like and I know
people think it's so weird like and I
get it but it's like it's awkward if you
know eight weeks in a row you say the
same exacts no it kind of it forces
accountability on yourself yeah is that
is that Saint Paul's Cathedral is that a
Catholic Church yeah yeah okay I went
there today it was really nice yeah yeah
Catholic they had a woman on the pulpit
I don't know how I feel about that
though on the what they had a woman on
the pulpit as the as the priest oh no
then that probably wasn't Catholic then
we don't we don't we don't allow female
priests
must have been something I I've thought
Saint Paul's Cathedral and also I'm kind
of being tongue-in-cheek but yeah yeah
no I'm like we don't do that that's
another thing I like about Catholicism
they don't let women be priests or
preachers it's in the Bible isn't it
isn't like a book of Timothy like women
should not have dominion over man or
something like that something like that
someone in the chat help us with that
scripture ah yeah no it's um that's and
the other thing I like is like we don't
change stuff so I I don't like it when
all these modern churches bring in like
modern things into the church like
transgender people yeah I'd like to get
or even like the music like I feel like
it's supposed to be the same I feel like
it's supposed it's not supposed to be
what's modern and hip we shouldn't be
bringing like Christian rap into the
church it's fine outside of church but
like into the church I just I think it's
supposed to be like Reverend and holy
yeah Orthodox does a good job of that
too I think that's why a lot of people
kind of like lost respect for the church
because they kind of see it selling out
I think that's why a lot of people are
converting to Islam because at least
Islam they they have a backbone they
stand upon their principles you're never
going to see see like a gay version of
Muhammad like they make a gay Jesus
absolutely yeah they should they should
yeah that's absolutely Haram no but but
they think it's hilarious to do like gay
Jesus or like you know like transgender
pastors and stuff and it's just like
this is clearly against what your
religious text says so even if you're
not a religious person I think people
don't respect
incongruency right you know I mean I
think that's number one thing people
don't respect so when you see that
they're like okay it's like what are you
doing yeah and one and it's like there's
no culture to like accept that they're
like no we do not we do not accept that
um yeah and and the problem too is so
this is what I've figured out about
religion in like the US with when it
comes to Christian Catholic like the
issue Catholics
that and say with Methodist like when
there's a governing body if one church
starts going crazy then the other
churches will say something right right
but the issue is the non-denominational
churches they don't have like any
governing body like a lot of them it's
just like this pastor that started a
church yeah
um and I understand why they started a
church because a lot of times they'll
say oh like we interpret the Bible this
way or that way right so I understand
why they do it but they're it because
there becomes problems because then it's
just a random guy interpreting the Bible
and he's saying okay well my my version
of what I understand is that Jesus
accepts gay people or yeah this this and
this it's like these Christian only fans
girls on the whatever podcast like I'm a
Christian only fans girl like oh okay no
you're crazy that's what you are yeah
well and I also think truth stands the
test of time I think so too so all these
like new age like new churches I just I
I don't know maybe what about
scientology though they're holding in
pretty hard I don't know anything about
I saw a Scientology Center in Tokyo it
was a nice building no I don't know
anything about it Tom Cruise
God does not and if you look at the
world today it is very obvious that the
devil does not oh okay so uh we got a
new member uh Karina she subbed me
yesterday and she just became a member
she's excited to see videos nice welcome
to Welcome to the jpt gang exit and I'll
go to the last one here with Muslim
quotes from you Christians don't have a
religion anymore because they tolerate
everything and stand for nothing that's
what I just said yeah exactly by the way
I actually agree with you the fact that
they they're tolerating way too much
Islam is the last religion on the planet
God is something to be feared respected
and to prove yourself too which means
you got to earn his right it's a hey I
want to earn your right your respect
right
how did you go if you don't mind talking
about your own Evolution because us as
men
if you knew me at 25 years old you
probably would have liked that party
with me I was a selfish guy I was a guy
you would have thought I was right and
we go through this phase of
where the selfishness kind of comes down
a little bit you still need to be
selfish because you need to be driven
but to the point where you're like
listen man I got to really do something
and then somehow somebody God enters
what's been your evolution of your faith
and where where are you at today yeah I
think Newton's I think it's Third Law
equal and opposite Force what you just
said there is absolutely true there has
to be equal and opposite Force to all
the evil in the world yeah and that the
equal and opposite Force to all that
evil has to be God and I've talked about
this at length even with atheists and I
try and say that regardless of whether
you're an atheist or not you're thinking
of God as a man in the sky but you need
to think of God as a concept as a whole
and once you do that it's impossible to
accept that he doesn't exist yeah right
I said to The Atheist I said let's say
there was two islands you're Shipwrecked
right and there's two islands both of
them are full of savages on wine one
Island
you're ruin your friendship wrecked on
one Island your friend goes and he
crashes and they they kill him and they
eat him and you go to another Island and
they want to kill you and eat you but
they don't because it's against their
religion
did God save your life
who cares who doesn't even know the name
of their God but their God said don't
kill Shipwrecked survivors and now
you're alive so they're gone save your
life the concept of God in and of itself
saved your life you own God just for the
concept of it the idea of it so even the
idea of opposing evil as a whole is a
belief in God so you're either an evil
person or you believe in God in some
regard
and then
I became once I understood that there
had to be an equal and opposite Force I
was raised Christian I live in a
Christian Nation the Romania is actually
that's funny because you know uh that's
that because you know did you know I was
in school to be a pastor
no yeah I could tell
him I got kicked out
why
sleeping with one of the girls
yeah that'll do you're not allowed well
she came on to me she was this hot
Mexican girl and she was like you know
predatory coming onto me but I used to
be I know the bible really well that's
why I do like my show like I call it the
red pill Sunday sermons and I just kind
of add biblical lessons to you know
modern day self-improvement techniques
and you know I went to school to get my
degree in Psychology University of
Central Florida and I got my degree and
then so throughout the entire like
science program you know they kind of
beat my religion out of my head they
kind of like you know made me kind of
become an atheist but then recently like
what Tate's saying right now me
personally I'm not just saying this a
copy Tate it's just I think we just have
parallel thoughts
um I've just been seeing like legitimate
evil in the world in my opinion right
and I'm just thinking
they're like these people are so evil
and some of these people I saw a
transgender guy have a fake pregnancy
thing on his stomach and then take a
knife and like stab his stomach fake
blood came out and he pulled out a baby
and like like a fake baby and all this
blood and he was like pulling out all
these fake guts and I'm just looking at
myself and I'm like
how is this even about Pride like this
guy looks demon possessed this guy looks
like an actual demon-possessed person
like what normal person would put that
entire thing together and think that's
okay to do in public
they become like shells of themselves
you ever see pictures of these people
when they're like younger and they look
like happy and full of life and then the
left just like destroys them
destroys them are you familiar with the
Thousand stare
right now so that's a red pill
terminology it's called the Thousand
stare it's like when a girl has
just been like her body count is through
the roof if you look at their eyes it's
like a lifeless stare
in every pot like even when she's
smiling her eyes are dead it's called
the Thousand there because it's
just she's just like a jaded war vet
like I told you it's just been through
two months did anyone on the show have
it yesterday
uh uh I don't want to say I don't know
who's watching
not you definitely not you no I have
another panel uh welcome to the jpt gang
noise ordinance welcome welcome I think
the second or third most Christian
country on Earth it's a very Christian
country here it's churches everywhere
they strongly believe and that's where I
began my journey but I always had a very
healthy respect for Islam because I
understand that to a degree to have a
religion at all you have to have an
intolerance to a degree yeah because
without an intolerance you don't have
rules you don't have laws you don't have
any like you said you have to earn God's
respect if you're a religion which is
tolerant of everything then you don't
have to earn God's respect you can be a
bad person and do bad things God loves
me so it's fine well no it's not because
that's not the point of the religion so
then you extrapolate that out and I'll
sit and thinking what's the primary
function of a religion
and the primary function of a religion I
don't believe is the religion exists so
I can live forever I mean that's a
that's a nice thought but I think on a
macro level the primary objective of a
religion is to restore and contain some
degree of traditional value within the
site how do you judge let me change the
way I worded that how do you judge the
success of a religion I don't think you
can judge it by the number of people who
join it because there's lots of people
who are Catholic who don't act Catholic
they don't act in any way particularly
Christian anyone can say this
and now I got a bad mouth too I swear
I'm just calling you I don't think I
think you're holding yourself to a way
high standard I don't think you're bad
at all no I'm telling you you don't know
how bad these girls are out here hoeing
you have no idea you are a saint yeah
but okay you're basically a virgin
compared to these girls okay but it's
like all right no because I did when I
was younger I wanted to wait till I was
married and I did it I was I felt guilty
for like years years and it's like just
because the cultures changed like I
don't feel like like human standards
have changed I don't know if that makes
sense like yeah yeah for sure God gives
Pat maybe he does I don't know like does
God give passes based on the culture no
yeah that's what that's what I mean like
I think of more like the women
throughout history I'm like if I sliver
into heaven
yeah yeah
but you don't else Catholics believe
that makes more sense to me we believe
in like layers of heaven so we believe
that's like layers of hell yeah we
believe in like there's better heaven
for better people and that makes so much
sense to me because I'm like do I and
I've heard now everyone's telling me I
guess Mother Teresa wasn't a good person
I don't know that's what I read on
Twitter would say I don't know if that's
true guys don't don't but this Mother
Teresa is just the example I'm gonna use
I'm like this woman dedicated her whole
life allegedly right I don't know but to
to like helping children like this whole
thing and I'm like would I get in the
same Heaven that Mother Teresa that
doesn't make sense to me but the layers
like when they taught me that I'm like
that logically I'm not I'm not like a
Bible I know all the verses I'm trying
to figure out what what have you didn't
like I know you're from from Chicago did
you shoot somebody like no no like why
do you think you're so bad I don't think
I'm so bad I just think like I think
there's like worse people but I think I
swear too much I don't think I go to
church enough like okay you know I you
know I try to be honest but I lie
sometimes you know you're you don't
swear as much as other girls though you
really don't uh it's a real turn off of
a girl curses in front of me like my
romantic interest just plummets but
these girls like dropping up on maybe
other words yeah yeah I do like to drop
an F-bomb here and there well
fighting evil how successful is it at
preserving the morality yeah of a
population in X parameter in an ex
geographical area
so when you look at it from that way you
can't say that Islam isn't the most
successful religion on Earth it's the
most successful in regards to opposing
evil it's the most successful in regards
to opposing its differing viewpoints
it's the most successful in regards to
having people act within the limits and
the confines of what it finds to be
moral and good to God yeah it's the most
adhered to it's the most feared it's the
most respected in most forms I feel like
a lot and also I'd like to think I feel
like London belongs to the to the
Muslims this part of London yeah like
when I go outside I'm like dude I
better like I I couldn't even believe
how many Muslims are here and you know
the women wearing the burqas and
everything I was just really yeah super
shocked yeah you don't really feel like
you're in London none of that was in the
James Bond movies I watched
I think they've had a lot of
the past couple of years a lot of
countries will do that to offset birth
rates because white people just don't
have kids yeah well because anytime a
country I mean it's just it's not about
white people either like it's happening
in Japan it's happening in Korea the
more industrialized a nation becomes
eventually the birth rate does take a
hit and once you're below 1.2 it's game
over you can't like you literally can't
replace like you're just on the downward
spiral wow so Korea is on the way out
Germany's on the way out uh Japan's on
the way out I mean Japan they sold more
uh senior diapers last year than baby
diapers
is that okay
because I'm like I've been to Japan when
I was a kid and on top of that like just
what I've seen I believe it but why they
don't they're like they have the biggest
um single childless women population
yeah and it's because the Japanese work
culture is probably the most extreme and
most toxic on the planet neck and neck
with Korea wow I think Koreans I think
Koreans on average the numbers are going
to be off but I think Koreans on average
are working anywhere I think 80 hours a
week 60 to 80 hours a week and like just
being a crazy workaholic is the social
Norm there the Japanese have a word for
death from Sudden Death from overwork
it's Karoshi and people will just be
like going hard hard hard working
working stressing themselves out to the
Max and just one day just die wow this
is from extreme amount of stress this
happened to women in their 20s happened
to men in their 20s some people like in
their 30s they're just walking and then
a lot of them honestly like uh they they
just off themselves they jump in front
of the train and kill themselves wow
yeah it's a big thing out there but
because you know Japanese Excellence is
something to be definitely noticed in
the world because like the way the
Japanese do something like the customer
service the uh quality of their products
the efficiency is is literally the best
in the world but it comes at a price of
like extreme pressure I can think a lot
of Japanese when they leave Japan they
just feel like oh like I have escaped
the pressure of Japan you know so the
extreme toxic work culture is why they
don't get married why they don't have
children because a lot of people just
don't have time you know again like in
Japan I think for men it's like 27 for
women it's 26 but ages 18 to 39 these
people have zero sexual experience
they're all virgins that's one in four
people in the whole country
do you
because of they have like a ton of debt
don't they we every country is dead no
but I thought there's I thought there's
this one of the worst I could be wrong
yeah I thought I so I'm wondering if
they have to like work no it's not
something it's it's the work culture I'm
telling you like there like there's a
certain way to give your business card
in Japan you have to like hand it with
two hands they have to receive it with
two hands you gotta take it put it on
top your business card holder on top of
the table and then like whoever senior
on the rankings of the person in front
of you you have to put like their card
at top and then put their card at the
bottom there's a way to bow when you're
leaving you gotta hit them with the 90
and the 90 degree angle wait for the
elevator to shut keep your head down
there's just so many rules and so many
nuances to like everyday business that
make it just hyper hyper stressful for
the average person in Japan and they
adhere to it and I love Japanese culture
but that's the part that is absolutely
detrimental there's just like these
toxic toxic work culture
uh welcome
to the jpt gang super RC we got another
one but
yeah when I went to Japan when I was a
kid you know well yeah I was my mom sent
me there by myself what'd you do
um I stayed with her friend from high
school like they're like my mom
literally sent me on a Plane by myself
get out of here I was obsessed with
Japan when I was a kid I really like I
had a manga face really what kind of
manga
um I don't remember the books anymore
because it was like when I was in Middle
School but I used to draw it too yeah
and then uh my mom I I guess there were
some inappropriate manga stuff like it
was pretty graphic and my mom was like
what are you reading and then he like
Banned Me from manga do you know that
the number one selling comics in the
world now are Japanese manga I believe
it I remember really like you gum
because you know why why because
deputies refused to go woke
oh it's just no woke there's
strict gender roles you know they draw
sexy women they draw masculine men I
mean and that's why Japanese video games
too are like literally the best in the
world like there's like all these
American video games and I just go it's
so woke and people are just sick and
tired of this woke they're just
like you know what I play video games I
read Comics I watch movies to escape
from the daily hell of what culture
every day you know what I noticed all of
the movies now the main chick is
um she's like a tomboy or she's like
becoming more and more masculine and the
lead guys are becoming more and more
feminine like I watched this one where
the lead chick
um basically the guy left his girlfriend
for her in the end but she was like the
the pretty girl with the like the girly
girl she was the Tomboy and the guy left
her and like it's even in like the
Taylor Swift song like she wears short
skirts I wear t-shirts she's cheer
captain yeah you don't yeah and so it's
like they're putting it in the media
like that the women need to be less
feminine that's not what works Avril
Lavigne too is I was singing about that
stuff too oh yeah and then they ah the
Olsen twins had a movie too and they
painted the girly girl it's like the bad
one yeah who's in control of the movies
I don't know who that who is I don't
know we should just watch this show okay
it's the most fear yeah it's the most
fear but what is respect without fear
do we respect Men We Don't Fear
but there's a man who could do
absolutely nothing to you on any level
at all
you might be nice to him sure because
we're not bad people but would you
really respect it if you could take his
chick in front of his face set his car
on fire he wouldn't do a thing you
wouldn't respect him you might be nice
to him because we're not bullies but he
wouldn't respect him respect and fear
are linked they're not always the same
thing and you can you can maybe have
fear without respect but it's very hard
to have respect without fear but also I
I heard someone say once that we see the
world as we see ourselves if you're if
Thief you think everyone's a thief if
you're a liar you think everyone's a
liar and I I kind of agree with that I
understood that
I also like to think we see religion as
we see ourselves I like to see myself as
a person whose respect you have to earn
I like to see myself as a person who has
strong rigid boundaries I like to see
myself as a person who will stand up and
say no that's wrong I like to see myself
as a person who's not afraid of being
shamed by whatever Community for saying
I don't agree with that particular ideal
I like seeing myself that way so if I'm
going to see myself that way then I'm
going to naturally align with a religion
that operates within that form so when I
say Islam is the last religion on Earth
I say it because it seems to be the only
one who will stand up and say no
we don't care no yep that's not what the
book says no
I was raised Christian and and Muslims
as a whole we have no problems with
Christians none at all I don't want you
to think I'm anti-christian like I
dislike Christians we don't have a
problem with Christians we believe in a
lot of the same things we believe in
Jesus we put more respect on the name of
Jesus than most Christians do
I just don't like the idea of people
saying they're a Christian and saying
but because I'm a Christian I can do
whatever I want and throw all the rules
away none of it matters because once you
have that level of Tolerance you no
longer have a religion Islam seems to be
the last religion left with parameters
if you don't parameters you're not
religion at all
so the closer I found myself to God the
closer I suffer I found myself those
long that's just how it ended and Andrew
speaking of fear one could argue that
Islam these days certainly in the last
20 years with the war on terror they've
also been the most vilified absolutely
right so you know everything that we've
seen happen with
extremism and everything that's going on
all over the world how are you grappling
with that you've been a Christian for
for years now Islam everything and you
know what's you know what that's such an
interesting question because when I was
younger especially when I was an atheist
I would I would sit and I'd sit and
think
people are really doing Terror taxing
and doing all this crazy stuff because
you know they're upset over a cartoon
that's so stupid and nobody nobody
should kill Charlie hebdo everything
nobody should kill anybody nobody should
kill anybody I'll make that very clear
but also part of me is now saying
why would you want to insult the profit
for billions of people why would you
want to do that I'm not saying you I'm
not even I don't want to make the
argument against Free Speech I'm saying
you couldn't be allowed to this is a
sensitive subject I'm just saying what
kind of person wakes up and thinks I
want to do that I don't know I just
don't think that's a healthy mindset
like when I see these satanists and
they're especially in America and
they're doing let's keep it on
Christianity these satanists and they're
dressing up Jesus is gay and all this
stuff like that's not done in any kind
of good faith yeah there's no good
reason to do that that's done with
genuinely malicious intention and what
kind of people want to do that and then
the answer by extension is
I thought America was a Christian
country so how can you have a Christian
country where the the prophets of the
religion are mocked to the highest
possible levels within the confines of
the country and and it's promoted
is that Christian country
it doesn't seem a Christian country to
me I don't think the same thing would
happen with Islam and Saudi Arabia I
can't imagine that no so how can you say
we're a Christian country but everyone's
mocking Our God on the streets do you
think I have a personal theory that
the downfall of America because it is
absolutely downfalling uh
is directly connected to America
straying away from Christian values yeah
I agree with you I think that the more
you make a country Godless the more they
like they do Godless things
and it's like when you rate like we're
racing these the Next Generation you
know it's crazy we're raising the next
generation of kids to spend 30 minutes
with our family a day so who's raising
them the state yeah you go to school
they spend eight hours in indoctrination
machines yeah you then you know you
might go home and then you might go to a
practice uh a music whatever your thing
is theater whatever so now you're
spending time with again people that are
not your family so it's like the parents
aren't even the number one influence on
the kids anymore yeah their friends and
whoever the hell is teaching them which
a lot of times is the single childless
women like I've heard from so many men
they don't date teachers because they're
nuts yeah oh yeah well I mean for me I
get I catch a lot of flax sometimes
because I say when I marry my wife that
I don't want her to work I want her to
be a state I want to be a full-time
mother and wife because who like God
knows who these people in the daycare
are you're just like oh what's this like
sunshine in daycare okay like you're
gonna take care of my kids sure have you
seen like that one daycare when they
like gave the kids like Hulk Hands and
they had like a like a fight club going
on in the daycare you have no idea
what's going on with these people let
alone these teachers teaching your
students are you teaching your kids you
know well I can't even think of it's
like weird when you get older and you
think back to conversations adult adults
had with you as a kid and you're like
why were they talking to me about that
what do you mean what's an example
um like I had one teacher that showed us
CNN kids and this isn't a Catholic
school why is she I had another teacher
tell this is kind of a random thing but
it's like an indoctrination but I
remember it it was like she said that
business like that she sees the price
difference it was like an economics
teacher or something she sees the price
difference between the the Walmart and
the rich neighborhoods and the Walmart
and the poor neighborhoods and she
thinks it's so mean that the business
owners charge the poor neighborhoods
more Oh I thought it would be the
opposite no because people steal in the
poor neighborhood so it raises the price
that's why yeah yeah that's because I
looked into it later but the point is
she's putting her moral like her her
obvious philosophy on to Kit where it's
like and I know it seems small but I
could think of like or even T adult
teachers talking to us about like like I
remember
um I wasn't really invited to many
parties in high school but but I did
throw one my senior year of high school
I did I got caught though yeah are you
at your parents house yeah you know
what's crazy you're 19 siblings yeah you
know no I'll tell you what happened
every summer so I would play volleyball
and it was really competitive like all
of my teammates went to a division one
like it was a very we were top like 20
or 30 in the country for club like we
was a really competitive team and so my
parents every summer would leave for
like a month and I would be home in this
big house for a month I never did
anything until my senior year I was like
this one time I got caught yeah how'd
you get caught do you know what's crazy
oh my gosh so my senior year I finally
like I was kind of I I played volleyball
and basketball so I did two sports so I
would go to school and I would do Center
yeah yeah and I would have um I don't
know four like four hours of go to
school and then I'd have four hours of
practice my school was 30 minutes away
my practice was 45 so I spent like I've
just always been really busy since I was
I was a kid
um and so what happened was my senior
year I finally had like a friend group
because I was so busy I just didn't and
we would also travel out of state on the
weekend so like a weekend I'd be in
Vegas the next weekend I'd be like I'd
be traveling for sports yes yes because
it was travel volleyball so
senior year I finally get a friend group
right and this is kind of new to me I
usually just have like two or three
friends and
um so I'm like all right I'm gonna throw
a party my mom won't find out she's gone
for a month like she's not gonna know
one day in the whole month I invite it
wasn't even that big my mom thinks it
was a rager mom if you're watching it
was like 20 25 people not bad I could
have I could have had a huge you know
and so what happened was we did the
party it was good we cleaned up I left
and what happened was I went to my
parents house in like their other house
and I met them does that make sense yeah
yeah yeah and what I didn't know was my
when my dad came back he found a garbage
bag full of beer cans uh but you know
what the weird thing was we didn't drink
beer so that that's what I said I was so
confused because I'm like they like my
parents must be making this up because I
know I did not buy beer for this party I
don't like beer and so and this was like
the first year I ever Dre like the first
yeah and and so what happened was my
friends in high that's why you know you
can't have too many friends my friends
in high school came back because they
knew I was leaving and they threw
another party and they didn't clean it
up and so then that that went through my
mom going through all of my text
messages
my dad yeah oh I'm gonna tell you this
was the worst part I'm gonna say it
online so you know I really I've never
been a big smoker you know but I this
was the first time I ever smoked weed
ever so they bring the weed over right
and they and I hated it I tried it and I
was like and so my friends took a
picture of me going like like like
because I didn't like it but my dad now
thinks I'm a pothead because he has a
picture of me with the weed how did he
get in the picture uh because they went
through my messages they took your phone
yes they took my phone because of the
beer thing that they came back and like
did and then it was like a whole Rabbit
Hole they just found out about
everything I got sent to Wisconsin for a
month with to live with my grandma in
the middle of nowhere yeah like there's
like no cell service at the time they
made me sell my my country music ticket
like yeah they were
yeah what'd you do with grandma though I
mean I actually was her designated
driver my grandma kind of like got like
I'm I'm German they they like to drink
you know what I mean so I remember I
took my grandma to a karaoke bar you
know it's funny I took my grandma to a
karaoke of like 16 or seven because I
graduated when I was 17. I was a year
young so I I think I was 16 or 17. and
I'm driving my grandma
to um to a karaoke bar with her friends
and it's all these old ladies and
they're all a lot of them because my
grandma was a widow and a lot of them
were widowed and I remember sitting
there listening to them talk about boys
that they're dated guys like older right
and I was thinking like wow they sound
exactly like me and my friends like
women never take and the funniest thing
the funniest thing was the the
difference about like older because you
have to think women outlive men so they
kind of re-enter the dating pool right I
mean you kind of hope they don't but
they do you know so so the the issue
though is when they date some of their
their dates die yeah so it's like
they're like oh I was seeing that guy
but he died oh I was seeing that guy but
he got cans and yet so
it's funny because when you're dating us
like I think my Grandpa died which early
60s so I think she was like almost 70 at
the time something like that but
remember some old people live to be 90
where some you know diets like the
average dies at 70 75 whatever it is so
it's kind of like you're kind of playing
roulette at that that's funny what's the
yeah and all the women are like VI like
they're dying they're literally dying
for a man you know I never got I threw a
party once when I didn't get caught but
the only hole in my game was so my mom
went out of town with some friends for
church and then when she was sleeping
one night I stole her car keys and I
gave it to my friend and I said go make
copies of these car keys and then he
made copies of car keys I put it back in
her purse she left I took the car for
the weekend but when she came back she
was like
the car is empty the gas is gone it was
full before I left and I just gaslighted
her I was like no no I don't know I
don't know I don't know
to the stage she doesn't know she's
probably watching now now she knows
sorry Mom yeah
but
um how do we get off on that what was
the the topic I don't remember all right
what is beeping
please is that outside oh that's outside
is that fire alarm
oh there we go no it stopped okay that's
okay building's on fire yeah I don't
know no air conditioning oh wait what
did I do did I just skip it uh I think
you did yeah oh no OMG guys
can anyone go back and see the time
stamp but when I stopped it I'll go at
literacy in the chat
your friends betrayed you yeah they did
betray me I was so guys you don't even
understand how confused I was because do
you know what it's like for your parents
to be like
oh we know
we know and they're like trying to get
information out of you
158-03 158 zero three and then me
they're like Never Smoke Weed you know I
did I never really got into it but
the you're an angel compared to what's
going on out there yeah I mean but it's
like you know just the average woman's
like obese so the bar isn't really high
it's it's all Netflix ha ha ha
that's not a Christian country to me so
if you're not a Christian country then
where's the religion where the religion
is supposed to enforce certain
boundaries you're supposed to at least
show it respect you know and it's also
kind of interesting because
in Christian countries there's more
respect for Islam than there is for
Christianity
in a Christian country name one they
still don't do it with the Islamic
Prophet why do you think that is it's
too much smoke
it's just not worth the heat yep
because because people believe and I'm
not advocating for violence on any level
I'm saying that even these degenerates
who are trying to destroy people's
belief in God like we've discussed
earlier because they don't want you to
have any Baseline morality if you
believe in god there are Commandments
yes and no that Baseline morality
prevents you being an absolute slave so
they're trying to destroy it but even
those degenerates who are trying to Mock
and disgrace God understand there's a
point where it just backfires and who
this is smoke
and they don't want the smoke and
shouldn't God be feared I'm scared of
God
it's the only thing I fear I Fear God
they can put me in jail I know I'm
telling the truth God's on my side I
Fear God
so God should be feared so once again
does anybody fear the Christian God I
haven't seen anybody scared of him in a
long time
and it's kind of crazy because it's very
interesting
the max the like the mass migration all
these things are leftist policies but
then also Islam is the most right-wing
religion it's kind of very interesting I
grew up in England and I grew up in
Luton which is a town which is mainly
Muslims like just it's a huge Islamic
community and there was a bunch of
English people who were complaining
about this too much immigration we're
losing our culture and I understood
their point absolutely but it is the
same people complaining about all the
left-wing LGBT and schools and all these
issues and I think the only allies you
have against this are the Muslims
they're the only allies you have in any
of this the Christians don't protest
against any of this stuff the Christians
don't the Christian there's very few
Christians will get up off their ass and
complain in fact I saw in 20 yesterday
one of the churches was lit up in
rainbow
I have nothing against gay people I
don't care
and that's actually another point I want
to make into about this thing I think
most people don't care and I think that
bothers them have you ever had a have
you ever had an argument with a girl
and she's like stropping around the
house she's huffing and puffing and you
just don't give a so she has to
keep up in the ante to eventually go
what's the problem because she tried the
low level stuff and you didn't care I
kind of feel like this has a remnants of
that I'm gay cool
I want to get married
I want to wave my dick in your kid's
face
[Laughter]
I feel like they're like they tried to
annoy us and we're like we don't give a
do whatever you want be a person we
don't care and now they're like okay
well we have to get to a limit where
they have to react we want attention now
we want them to care about what's the
right move on that well that's and
that's the point you know it's it's
difficult because there comes a point
where you simply have to address it and
now you have to oppose it and this is
sorry sorry to drop you but this is why
they're so careful and so clever with
what they do they package it all
together
lgbtq I would argue I don't know what Q
is firstly sorry I don't know what
you're questioning cue all right LG I
would argue that G and T are very
different things Beyond a gay man and
someone who's chopped the dick off are
very different things so they package it
all together so now because because the
spectrum of your enemy is so large you
have people who are complete fully this
way you're people who we accept and are
normal in society we have no problem
with gay people and they put it all
together you're an enemy of all these
people and they complicate the argument
and they mix it all together and now
you're a bigot and really you just want
your kids to be left alone really just
want to leave the children of course so
all you want to do is leave your kids
alone and then it's like okay I'm now
raising children I have more children
than most people would believe how do I
protect my children from this Insanity
yeah God
which God can protect my children
Allah Islam I'll move them to Dubai or
Saudi Arabia and none of this will
happen
can I trust a Christian Nation some of
them remaining is a Christian Nation and
to a large degree they oppose quite a
lot of this stuff
but they're also naive and they're also
EU and they also rely on bailouts and
grants and money and on a long enough
time frame even in the seven years I've
lived here I have watched certain
attitudes change because money buys
influence and power so Andrew not to cut
you off
how much of you converting from
Christianity to Islam is actually the
belief in God versus
the societal pressures that are facing
because it seems like it's a little bit
of both for you to believe in God you
have to respect him
how can I believe and put the put my
life in the hands of someone I don't
respect
and I'm going to respect a god which is
feared
yeah but it's a vertical relationship
right it's not a horizontal if you base
uh if you base it horizontally they're
going to disappoint you if you think
about if you're going to believe let's
go believe Prophet Muhammad his teaching
and let's go believe the Bible NIV and
Jesus father you know for God so loved
the world that he gave us you know you
gave your son for me let's say that's
true and you're doing it based on faith
who would do such a thing for me yeah
what a level of sacrifice for you to do
that who am I for you to be so worried
about me if you look at it from that
angle it's not necessarily coming from a
place of fear it's coming from a place
of Grace that's coming from a pla Grace
a place of love it's coming from a place
of absolutely you know or a different
feel because I do believe
uh the part that upsets me is the fear
aspect that they're allowing others to
mock your God to mock mock Jesus to mock
whatever religion it is you're a part of
you're kind of like they're just funny
man so no it's not funny you just cross
the line like JC has that one line where
he says don't tell me why the guy
what the guy said about me tell me why
he was so comfortable saying it to you
100 yeah tell me why say comfortable to
you so I think that's the part about
uh faith I understand when you're saying
to fear in the respect side so that's
the part where fear is needed I totally
agree but the part where you you were
making a point about lgbtq you're like I
don't even know what Q stands for is
questioning and then you're like well
I'm gay okay cool trans listen in
spectrum and he said on the if we were
to say which religions the far right
it's going to be Muslim totally get it
they're on the far right Christian today
is kind of going Center left today you
know like they're kind of being soft
right now okay so if I want to raise my
kids I'm going to take my kids to you
know Dubai and I'm going to take my kids
to Saudi Arabia why because I'm
defending against some of these immoral
philosophies that they have I don't want
to go there I actually understand that
argument yeah and and I truly and I want
to make one more point I do believe
there is one God and I believe there's
many different paths to God and I'm not
a religious scholar and I'm not an
expert on Islam I'm doing my best and
I'm reading the Quran as often as I can
and it does say that Christians on the
Day of Reckoning will see how close they
were to the truth and we are we are
allies we are not enemies in any regard
Christians and Muslims and I do believe
that the idea of Christians and Muslims
shaking hands and saying let's put an
end to a law this garbage would be
fantastic I'm not anti-christian in any
regard I just found myself as I became
more and more religious seeking and
looking for
a faith which normally I could be proud
of but a faith which was guiding in
regards to I don't know what a Christian
would answer to certain questions
nowadays what does a Christian answer to
I'm a transsexual and I'm not sure your
kids my genitals what's the Christian
well Christian's supposed to say no did
you see the the other day they had like
this
Pastor I saw this on disclose.tv it's
Twitter
they had this
of course like some big fat guy
who is like a feminate he had long hair
he looked like
I don't know he looked like he was dark
he made me look like Pakistani or
something I don't know are you Indian I
look more Pakistani but he was saying
like uh he was just going so super woke
he was like giving this speech on a
Altar and he was like black lives matter
and God is queer
this is a priest wow and I just like
I don't understand
either are people this
or is there some Insidious agenda to
make Christians look like fools because
let me tell you something if some dude
came out and said like Muhammad or Allah
was queer
like it's only a matter of time before
that guy is ends up on a milk
carton whereas have you seen this guy
um why do you think they're doing that
what's this thing because it's like
misery loves company they don't want to
be by themselves so they're trying to
make us like that God like why do you
think it's disgusting why do you think
older women give younger women such bad
advice I saw that on your show yeah yeah
yeah no it's like and that's that's the
thing that's what bothers me it's like
okay hey older women are haters on
younger women like I'm I'm 26 so someone
watching me could be 16. yeah and it's
like what I'm gonna say oh go to cot
like do the same like rap like it's like
you can
it people aren't perfect but what I
don't like is like lying to younger
women that are impressionable and don't
know better yeah and I think it's the
same thing with the gay community that's
why they push it in schools because
misery loves company they're miserable
there's no way you're chopping your off
and you're a happy person there ain't no
way and so it's like okay it's kind of
like when one girl becomes a then
all of her friends become yeah
because you know how it's like one girl
gets divorced and they all get divorced
one becomes gay they all become gay
because it's like they do not want to be
by themselves yeah and I noticed this
too I noticed a pattern like when a
group of girls will be like there's a
bunch of like hoes and then there's like
one Pure or innocent girl they'll like
push her to go be a hoe they like want
to corrupt her because I think that's
one thing that's been like a real red
pilling in my life lately is like the
The Depths that people will go to
fulfill misery loves company like they
will absolutely go out of the women like
you you've seen it will go out of their
way to destroy another girl's
relationship just because
she is jealous because she doesn't have
a relationship because women typically
don't get happy for other women in a
relationship like they typically get
salty because they have to go home and
reflect on all the dick they've taken
and be like damn and I'm here
still alone and I'm getting fat and I'm
getting wrinkled and I you know I can't
keep up with these new young girls they
get salty because they they realize like
they don't have what it takes to like
lock down a quality guy so when they see
like their friend who may be pretty or
even the friend's not that pretty but
she's happy and in a relationship with a
guy and things are going well like the
moment there's like one little rocky
part of a relationship which are
inevitable to come right
what do they say just dump him dump him
you can do better break up with him he
you deserve better baby and that's the
thing the grass isn't always greener on
the other side but we tell women that
we're the prize that there's always
going to be better when it's like a lot
of times there's not no it's not and
guys fall into the same trap too you
know like you if it's like you have to
cash in and go home and leave the casino
eventually Eddie Murphy talks about that
and is one of his stand-ups and he's
like you know you're just out there
gambling with your dick and hoping you
don't get you know herpes or some kind
of like or get the wrong crazy woman
pregnant men and women they talk about
this in a book called The Psychology
money and greed is one of the number one
thing that gets people to lose money
lose relationships lose opportunity is
like oh I mean how many people made
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in the last crypto bull run but
they were just so greedy that they held
on to the Bitcoin they held on they were
like yeah it's gonna go to 100 000. yeah
it's gonna keep going it's going to keep
going blinded by greed only to lose
everything at the end same thing with
relationships like women men women
always kind of think like you know
there's a better guy out there like my
perfect guy is just out there I just
haven't like the fact that every time I
go through a relationship and I'm
completely the whole thing up and
I failed relationship after relationship
relationship that's not on me I just
haven't found the perfect guy I haven't
found the right guy once the right guy
comes he's gonna fix everything and it
doesn't help you because it's like
you're not learning anything we don't
take accountability you know what's
crazy
men want younger women but I think more
men would be open to dating not old old
women but like say like a girl that's 30
like a guy that's 45 right I think
they'd be more open to it but the
problem is they're not finding that the
young women or the older women are more
mature they're finding that they're less
mature than the young women so it's like
if you can't like if you're gonna be
older at least be wiser but the problem
is they have this it's so crazy to me
how I mean even yesterday who was more
mature on the couch the most mature mine
was the youngest Kamara yeah yes I like
her yes yes and it's like this is what
we're giving yeah well and then you know
and because I saw somebody say this
right because
um honestly Tinder Bumble hinge these
things up American society you
know in in Japan they're trying their
damnedest to get Tinder off the ground
and they just can't they just can't make
it work
um but the thing is this like back in
the day right pre-social media
pre-dating apps like is someone dumped
you you got to go home and be like why
did I I why did I get dumb this
sucks gotta look in the mirror like well
I am kind of fat I'm kind of ugly and my
teeth are yellow you know all these
different things you would look and be
like I am kind of an you have to
like reflect and be like damn it I gotta
do better but now people are just like
that it's the other person's fault
everybody's so narcissistic nowadays and
so like it's the other person's
fault uh let me just delude
Myself by finding cheap sex with some
other or some other man
you know nobody's taking a moment
to sit down and be like
where did I up you know what I mean
and I talked about this when I was on
Brandon Carter's uh podcast couple weeks
ago Victory talk and I say like when
you
don't take accountability
for your failures you leave power on the
table you know when you take
accountability you're like you know what
I am kind of an I am kind of
uncaring of a person or I you know post
my too much on Instagram
or only fans maybe I should delete that
there's no moment where people are
like okay wait
I up
let me make myself better and then I can
attract somebody better because the
reality is in current dating structures
that are happening right now you're if
you're constantly attracting shitty
people into your life
that's on you
because you're you're what you're
putting out there is what you're
attracting and another thing is this
even if you are a good person but you're
constantly attracting shitty people then
that means you you have a pretty bad
picker your picker is broken or
self-esteem or self-esteem right but you
leave so much power on the table when
you just you know well they say like
when they when you point the finger at
somebody no you have three fingers
pointing back at you no that's what I
always say I think everything in life is
my own fault yeah even if somebody does
you wrong it's like okay you you have to
look at where what did you do to attract
that person yeah because they're and
this is like another thing it's like
when women will talk about being in
toxic relationships it's always them
that they were toxic but you cannot I'm
sorry I just do not believe you could be
in a toxic relationship long term
without being toxic yourself well yeah
and and I'll even say it like I'll even
say there's been times where I was
absolutely toxic in a relationship you
know really now we're getting spicy yeah
no I won't give us a jpt exclusive how
are you toxic
um I mean I think going through a guy
phone is toxic I've done that then every
girl on this planet is toxic
yeah you're so nice
every girl in this planet is toxic
that's toxic you shouldn't go through
something dude girls girls bro girls
can't even help themselves they can't
they're like a girl listen let me tell
you about female treachery okay if you
have like a four digit passcode on your
phone a woman will like look over your
shoulder you could cover your pace and
shame
a woman will like get a one digit at a
time and be like detective and
like figure out your passcode that's why
when they do like this and then
they're like oh yeah sorry I didn't get
your text like you you got my text
you goddamn liar because you want to go
full Batman detective mode to like crack
my password and even when you change
your password they're like wait did you
change your password like how did you
know I changed my password psychopath
how did you like what's going on over
here you another trick we do I'll tell
you what let's hear it you you tilt it
and the light to see where it swipes
uh
cause usually there's like dots yeah and
you know when a girl too like I dated a
girl and she had like a screen protector
on her phone so you couldn't see from
the side yeah I was like what are you up
to
so what do you what what are
you up to you know so no I mean female
treachery is there but again men and
women men and women everybody at home if
you suck at relationships start blaming
yourself
find problems within yourself and
improve yourself and watch the quality
of your life go through the roof you
know I'm friends with a guy called King
Dre on uh on social media's great guy
and we are we're having a conversation
and we're you know him and I both kind
of leveled up in our 30s you know became
financially successful individuals and
we both have nudged like really high
quality women like all of a sudden like
shooting up I remember he does a lot of
he's gone to a lot of things he's like
you know he's gone through therapy talks
about on his podcast and he's overcome a
lot of his demons I've gone to a lot of
therapy good therapists masculine
therapists I've overcome a lot of my
demons and then now like a lot of like
high quality like attractive women are
coming out of Woodwork and we were both
having a conversation we're just going
like damn maybe we were just shitty
individuals and like now that we got our
sorted out we're attracting quality
women and it's so true that's a you know
one thing with the red pill and all the
people talking about dating advice the
bottom line is this if you're
consistently attracting people that you
are not satisfied with
in the dating Marketplace that's a
direct reflection
of your value
you know you got to level up
if you don't level up you're going to
keep on attracting what you're getting
well and then it's like if you admit
there's a problem you can work on fixing
it yeah like it's that and a lot of
people take the red pill as trying to
like on women or like try like but
it's like we can't even admit there's a
problem like okay if we're overweight
let's lose weight yeah you know if if
you're traumatized from your ex let's
work on that like what do you see them
all attack me because I said I don't
want to traumatized woman in my life no
you know no you don't why would you yeah
I like I I feel the same way I don't
think it's the same I don't want to
Super traumatized guy that's bitching
about his ex who cheated on him or
whatever like that we don't we don't
want to hear that either and like
like girls we have all like we all know
that guy that's super jealous or can and
not not like the fake one you know not
like but like real like crazy I don't
know you're right no I'm listening this
is a great story no no no but it's like
so it's like
I just we don't want traumatized people
either so I don't know why we are
demonizing men for not wanting
traumatized women why would you I don't
want to traumatize employee I don't want
to traumatize girlfriend I don't want to
deal with traumatized family members
like go over there drink yourself to
death like get away from me if you don't
want to help yourself and you're gonna
just self-destruct like get out of my
sight I don't want to deal with that
yeah women used to like die with secrets
you know what I mean yeah now they talk
about it on Tick Tock yes
well I know what my I know what my
Muslim friends would say I didn't if
you're a Christian I don't know how
you're supposed to act I don't know what
you're supposed to adult I don't get it
anymore the True Believer the True
Believer the True Believer but how many
are True Believers and I mean I don't
know I see all over Twitter all these
churches are losing their minds it seems
very complicated Islam seems very very
simple
you know what's right you know what's
wrong I have a question regarding we
talked about tolerance and acceptance
the other end of that is extremism so
I'm a Jew Christian
Newfound Muslim respect looking of us
all hanging out here yeah you know the
beginning of a joke somewhere you know
so I'm talking about accepting the I
think we have gay friends you have
lesbian friends they're bisexual these
friends of Destiny
[Laughter]
you know I'm not a yeah this is not my
wheelhouse nor any of our wheel houses
but one could argue that you know on the
on the opposite end of the acceptance
and the tolerance is like absolute
extremism yeah and I'm sure the allies
of the LGBT will point to Islam and
point to the Middle Eastern countries
important to the North African countries
that have Islam as their religion and
say they are the most extreme when it
comes to LGBT they say that it should be
illegal to be gay and in some countries
you should be killed if you are gay this
is just I'm just part of your life
you're right and it's a super
interesting argument because I will I
will sit here and say that I guarantee
in most Islamic countries there are gay
people and I guarantee that they have
gay relationships and nobody cares as
long as they're not trying to inflict on
the children it's illegal to walk down
the street and do indecent things in
front of children but I guarantee if you
were gay in a lot of these countries no
privately nobody would care because
they're trying to preserve the family
unit and to a degree you have to always
protect innocence when you were talking
about extremism I would be friends with
a gay person yes I'm a Muslim but I
would be friends with a gay person
because if a full-grown man decides one
thing that I was always really thankful
for my mom about was she was very big on
like keeping kids as innocent as long as
possible she was not with this whole
like we need sex ed in school she was
not with this whole like like the kids
need to have adult conversations she let
us believe in Santa Claus until we were
old as hell like nobody else believes
that's good yeah but it's it's because
like you're not adult you're a kid and I
just don't understand like why we have
these like adults that want to ruin
children's innocence even sex I am so
anti-sex at in schools yeah so it's
disgusting why on Earth are we teaching
children how to have sex you know like
why are we teaching them about STD like
why do they need to know that and and
the thing is what the school doesn't
understand is each kid is different yeah
like I have a bunch of siblings like I
can think of one sibling that needed a
sex ed talk as soon as possible
immediately and I could think of another
that would have been gone maybe yeah I
don't want to throw this brother under
the bus oh you just did yeah well I got
a lot of brothers who know which one
okay but and then I have a sister who
it's like you know she always seemed
like she was younger and so like she
would have been fine until she was like
17 18 because she was just more innocent
and so but oh but who knows that not the
school the parents because they know
their kids and they're the only one ones
that have a vested interest in how the
children turn out yeah like a stranger
some feminist
single childless women miserable person
miserable that's inflicting her
onto your kids because she doesn't have
any of her own and she's just getting
pumped and dumped so it's like her
hatred for men is building yeah it's
she's not gonna have the best interest
of your kids the parents have the best
interests you know I when I was in when
I was five years old I had a
kindergarten teacher she was this mean
black lady named Mrs Mrs Jefferson right
and I remember one time there's this kid
his name is Jonathan Lopez and he was
just like doing these like ninja kicks
into the air right I remember at
one point she snatched his leg
and like flung him to the ground and
then dragged him into the other room and
was like you need to watch this boy and
take care of him because I'ma whoop his
ass and I had never even seen this level
of violence and all I know is a
five-year-old kid I was just terrified I
was so afraid I didn't want to tell my
mom and my dad right and as I grew up I
was like this woman was legitimately
like abusing children in public school
and like well you gotta ask yourself
like
how often is that happening and just the
whole vetting procedure for teachers is
just like I don't know it's absolutely
insane that what we just let these
teachers go on and do with these kids
and nowadays like I see you know
unfortunately one of my one of my toxic
traits is I like to I like to check
World Star Hip Hop
once a week yeah yeah I like to check it
and I just see these students yeah
mouthing off to these teachers and like
fighting them in school and I'm just
like what who is raising these
animals like stay I mean I I don't know
it's insane it is insane who influences
your kid the most it's it the the
average kid spends like 30 minutes a day
with their parents that's so sad yeah
because think about okay you go to
school from like 7 A.M to I don't know
three it's not like I mean most kids
roll out of bed they go to school right
I mean they might eat breakfast but okay
and then they come home and then at
least where I grew up everyone had
extracurricular activities right so I
had like a bunch of volleyball my my
sister did Bat or what did Eva do oh she
did horseback riding okay you know so we
each had a different not a bad thing but
it's like the school ends up having more
influence a lot of times than the
parents it's it's honestly when you do
that kind of stuff like it's just I
don't know man like Outsourcing that
stuff to your children like I said like
I I will not marry a woman who was like
I want to be a career woman I'm like
well you're gonna go
back to the streets where you
belong because I don't want some
psychopath like raising my kids or
indocturing them like honestly I'm on
the path of thinking like I want to
homeschool the kids too yeah no I think
it's better
I can't really add so I was like we
might need to I was I was thinking I was
like I I want to homeschool my kids but
I'm like I'm really bad at math so I
might need to get someone else you can
hire a tutor and bring him to the house
and supervise them you know because you
know you know people employees everybody
does a way better job when you're
watching them correct and um you know
looking at this whole situation with
like just the increasing Insanity of
like what's happening with these kids
like my mom too like I understand now
but like because I would go to the
church a lot and my mom would always
like after church she would pull me
aside she's like none of those men are
touching you are they like because
nobody touching you in church like what
the hell are you talking about nobody's
nobody's doing anything she would ask
all of us and she would always like
interrogate us like is anybody being
weird at church is anybody touching like
no Mom we're just going to you Church
we're hanging out but now that I'm older
I understand like how she was just like
all right I would have everyone sleep
over at our house she would never let us
go there oh yeah yeah I mean once or
twice but she had to know she didn't
know she didn't meet the mother yeah
yeah like we would always like there's
so many kids that kind of grew up around
our house because we would always be the
family that had so am I through the
party my mom was so mad she's like I
want to let you have them over dude and
my mom was spot on like there's uh this
is this is like this is a little it's a
little x-rayed story I don't know if I
could tell you
maybe we should just go no no
it's up to you it's up to you okay so
when I was when I was 18 years old and
Senior High School right my friend's mom
was after me uh I've heard this kind of
story so many times she was 39 and I was
18. no and my mom when she met her she's
like I do not like that lady she's like
I don't know why but I just do not like
that lady and I didn't sleep with her
but but she did things to me and like
you know I went to school I was like I'm
the man you know is your friend
embarrassed I hit no I didn't tell
anyone oh you didn't tell him I hope
he's not watching I'm not gonna say his
name but let me reverse calculates the
numbers
single mom of course single mom listen
what I did okay she she told me she's
like okay
miss the bus on purpose
I'm gonna come over to your house
and then after that I'll drive you to
school so she came over
she did something to me and then she
took me to Chick-fil-A bought me
Chick-fil-A and then I ate it in the car
and then she drove me to my high school
and dropped me off and I was like I came
into school second period and all my
friends like where the hell are you I'm
like
I gotta start to tell you boys but then
like you know because when you're a guy
and you do that you're like yeah
whatever I'm the man but you know when
you look back on you're like this
dude really this is weird this
39 year old Predator I have
heard that story so many like different
guys have told me that story but as
instead of a mother I've heard that
before too oh my gosh I've heard on the
Pod guys that were dating a girl and the
mom was hitting on him too oh wow yeah
yeah and I've also heard stories of
babysitters that like watch the watch
them
um
it's it's no listen it is bad out there
bro these chicks there there are I
they're I'm not gonna say anything but
there have I have coached men in my
community who have dealt with you know
unwanted advances from women in their
youth you know like 12 13 14 and it it
they carry this trauma into a adulthood
and it really messes with them you know
so it's like this whole and again it's
all the mainstream media right like
don't you remember like in the ER well
you're kind of younger than me but like
in the 80s and the 90s there was this
big campaign in America like all men are
pedophiles after children like trying to
like be predatory terms so they would
always be like keep that man away from
the kids keep that man away from the
kids and I think that was a big thing
that they were just constantly
demonizing the men but now you look at
the things I mean how many times do you
see like a like a woman who's a high
school teacher
sleeping with young boys sending nudes
how dumb do you have to be it's like
yeah I'm gonna send nudes to a 15 year
old boy it's predatory especially and
then they'll get them like they'll
they'll get them pregnant because they
don't know any better yeah like I mean
they're so nice like they are naive yeah
yeah they don't even know how pregnancy
Works no no uh I'm gonna read a Super
Chat real quick um he's new and Islam
was in jail for a long time needs to
learn more adultery is one of the
biggest harams Myra is a hypocrite about
it Judaism Christianity and Islam No
Other path decision is his decision to
make but I must protect innocence as a
man so I must protect children if two
men if two full-grown men decide to have
a fight Let them fight if a full-grown
man decides to pick on a kid that's
unacceptable so I must protect innocence
so I agree with the extremism point but
I have no problem with full grown men
doing what they want to do maybe some
Islamic scholar is going to watch this
and get mad at me I don't have a problem
being gay with gay people and being
friends with a gay person I don't care
my problem is when you take a person who
is unarmed who's innocent who is
programmable like a child and start
inflicting your worldview on them that
is disgusting and it's immoral that is
unfair and it can't be accepted on any
level and that's the reason
homosexuality is genuinely outlawed in
these countries not because they fear
what two full-grown men are going to do
they fear what's happened in the west so
two full-grown men are going to purport
on the minds of children which aren't
theirs that's what they're afraid of
you know I don't know if you saw the
interview uh CNN uh is interviewing this
the in Africa and I have the video I
don't want to play the video obviously
the leader yes let's talk about
democracy he says democracy look you can
do whatever you want to do so he says
what do you think about gays and his
reaction was like what do you mean what
they do I don't think I don't agree with
what they do you think that's okay
anyways he's given his argument right
and the lady's reaction is like how
could you says look you keep your
beliefs to you do not bring it to our
country here right uh the the challenge
goes back to remember how you're like
the girl that you're dating was like so
what happened I asked you to bring the
oranges from the store how come you
didn't bring it welcome haha gotcha 56
to the jpt gang I forgot hey so how
about this Amazon and you know that's
why you love your mom more than you love
me and nothing yeah
there's a fight right okay
well
is the mistake being too tolerant from
the beginning
is the mistake being too accepting from
the beginning is the mistake of you know
you know like the the fear when I talk
to Second Amendment guys in the fear
about well you know what's wrong with
them doing background checks what's
wrong with them doing this he says look
that's that's how it starts you give
them the background checks then they're
going to come for everything oh you're
over exaggerating no one's coming for
your guns well you also said 20 years
ago Hillary Clinton marriages between a
man and a woman and the sanctity of
marriage 20 years later so that is the
fear where one must watch this as a case
study say somebody start a new country
and saying look here's where we stand
these are the laws we're not touching
we're not going to be doing XYZ you've
been too tolerant and now you're paying
the price for it and now you're reacting
to it and that's exactly why you
completely nailed it if you give an inch
to take a mile and that's why I think in
a lot of these countries they have an
official it's officially illegal they're
actually quite tolerant of it more than
you'd believe I'm telling you you can go
to Jordan and your waiter will be a bit
fruity you can tell
nobody gives a right but they have
it officially illegal to prevent the
ever bleeding out into actually
affecting the mindset of society if you
can do what you want your full-grown man
but Society is based on family
traditional Family Values that's how our
society is based that's how we show
ourselves to the world and that is not
going to be affected or changed I was
going to say that's why you see the the
you talk about the collapse of Western
Society specifically America you see a
decline in values Wall Street Journal
came out with that article that said
Family Values plummeting religion
plummeting uh being a social uh being
Community organizer plummeting
everything's plummeting in America other
than money people are focusing on money
my neck is an application which allows
you to take a minute to connect with
influencers from all around the world my
name is Andrew Tate and I'm available to
speak directly to you on minute so so
it's interesting while you're while
you're talking about this whole religion
thing while you're in
um hey Pearl you look really fine today
by the way what's your thoughts on Circa
using the n-word freely and no one
calling him out is he is it hard r
I don't know keep me out of that one oh
no listen the chat though you guys need
to get these likes up to 1 500. we've
been born for an hour yeah what is even
going on here like is this a charity
there's 1 400 people right now if you
guys are 500 likes it's pathetic that's
pathetic what is this Destiny stream
guys we're gonna open the chat at 1500.
like is free a like is free push it talk
about this last time briefly yeah uh uh
being a Muslim yourself have some of the
most powerful Muslims reached out trying
to help out figuring out a way to get
you out yeah absolutely they certainly
have and also the amount I wonder why
America didn't try to get him out
like they got Brittany Greiner whatever
that basketball check uh I think it's
about the Matrix but dude that is like
what value does she like we traded like
a drug like no uh a gun
smuggling like dude that is like killed
a lot of people
for this chick who is smoking weed
well is she even a good basketball
player no she's really good she is she's
really good but what is the benefit of
that nothing it's not like the WNBA
makes sense I was about to say yeah as
good as she is I mean she's still in the
WNBA right right
yeah I don't you know what's funny I
watched the interview
um with the drug Smuggler and he's kind
of based he and he's not a drugs
oh yeah I saw a video and he was talking
about how America was losing its values
I was like is this man based
was completely incredible when I was in
the cell with Tristan he even said he
said
well I'm Christian nobody's written to
me yes yeah so it was kind of amazing to
support me that you have from the the
Brotherhood and you certainly feel part
of the family and I've had a lot of
support from them as a whole
um it was Ramadan at the time I was in
jail so my first Ramadan was in jail so
that was certainly interesting because
you eat when the Sun goes down and my
meal came when the sun was up so I'd
have to cover it up and try and hide it
from cockroaches and wait for the sun to
go down and then eat it cold by myself
but I felt like you know if you're gonna
do it the first time you may as well
jump in the deep end and do it hard so I
I did that and that was a experience
and jail as a whole I mean there's so
many stories I can tell there's so many
different ways I remember it there were
times I laughed
I will sit and say some of the best days
of my life were in jail get out of here
yeah and so I don't believe that
but there were days where me and Tristan
were finally in the same cell
there's times we laughed like we've
never laughed before I'll sit and admit
that's absolutely not really true I feel
like if you're going to be the kind of
person who strives for an exceptional
life which is what I am I think I'd be a
coward if I said I want an exceptional
life but I only want to be exceptional
in a good way I don't think that's
genuine I want an exceptional life
exceptional means away from the norm and
away from the norm means flying your
Bugatti on a jet to Dubai and taking
your own plane to meet it there and it
also means a Romanian dungeon quick
cockroaches on New Year's Eve they're
both exceptional experiences and the
times I was with my brother and it was
just him and I we truly had some genuine
days where we laughed like we always
laughed me and him laugh and have fun on
a private jet and we laughed and had fun
in a Romanian prison cell because that's
just who we are and I also have to give
my brother some credit while we're here
I would like to state that I absolutely
genuinely believe I have the best
brother in the world and I'll tell you
why
I always knew I had the best brother in
the world but he proved it in jail and
I'll tell you why
my brother was put in jail for being my
brother
he hasn't said any videos he hasn't said
anything on the internet Jesus said any
of the things I've supposedly said he's
not the Matrix isn't attacking him the
BBC doesn't print about him nothing why
was Tristan Tate in jail because it's
Tate brothers so they just took him and
threw him in a Cell now what's
interesting is when I got out of jail so
many people near me got Heat all
business partners got hate with attacks
they got hit with like a tax paperwork
and uh they were calling everyone who's
ever known me and ex-girlfriend's got
heat and all these people got heat and
some people complained some people
didn't but some people were like oh
since you've been in jail it's been so
stressful for me the media is outside my
house are stressful for you I was in
jail what do you want me to do and
people were complaining at me and as
these people start to complain I sat
there I said to Tristan
you got thrown in jail purely for being
my brother and never for a fraction of a
second did you even moan didn't even not
even for a fraction of a second did he
say oh they only put me here because of
you why am I here I'm innocent this has
nothing to do with me nothing in fact he
said the absolute opposite he said I am
so glad I went to jail with you I would
be furious if they sent you here by
yourself if they're going to lock you up
they better lock me up and there was a
time about two months in because there's
less media pressure on Tristan they were
talking about releasing Tristan first
and he was saying no I I won't leave
without Andrew
going down with the ship I won't leave
unless my brother leaves I won't leave
and he was telling the guards I won't
leave keep me here I'm not leaving and
they said the judge says you have to
leave you to leave because then I'll
stand outside the gate I'll sleep
outside
I ain't leaving this jail and our lawyer
said well we can make an appeal to just
release you because there's less media
scrutiny around you interested like no
Andrew's in jail I'm in jail refused to
leave he was adamant he had to stay
that's why that's why the elites hate
family
that's why the elite hate family because
if somebody would attack my family
I'm fighting tooth and nail to stop
everybody I mean you love your family I
mean you're so well adjusted because you
come from like uh like you're so normal
because you come from a normal family
you know what I mean we're like they
prioritize taking care you love and all
that stuff and when the thing is this
like how much money could somebody offer
you to betray your family
1.5 billion okay
zero right now yeah like if they were
tell if they try to tell me like hey you
know you got to go like take out your
mom or your brother your sister like how
much money there's no there's nothing
right now because it's like blood's
thicker than water Blood Thicker and
water no matter how people want to spin
it what is thicker than water I really
respect I respect I mean despite him
hating me I respect Tristan Tate for uh
for taking a stand like that because
that that thing right now too I feel
like people now are at an all-time high
for being snakes and disloyal I just
don't think I don't know maybe it's
because I'm getting older I'm just wiser
but I haven't I've never seen so much
snakes and shitty people in my life it
shows like feminine men to be that's
like women Behavior like how do they say
like women don't have friends because
they all hate each other yeah yeah yeah
or it's like men will insult each other
to their face but be best friend like
they would never betray each other ever
um and it just shows how feminine like a
lot of the guys are nowadays yeah I mean
yeah I know it I mean it's just but it's
atrocious but again that that right
there that loyalty that Tristan is
showing Andrew is
a great example to young men as well
because so many people nowadays they
don't stand for anything they're just in
it for themselves you know a lot of
people a lot of people would throw
Andrew under the bus like that but thank
God he has a good brother like that and
what was Tristan's incentive to do that
you know nothing but nothing familial
love and and loyalty to his brother
that's a respectable thing
it's a brother for me and it was the
same for me I said to Tristan if they
came into me and said Andrew go home
I'll be like no no way Tristan's in jail
I'm in jail we're in jail together he
never for a second complained never
bitched never moaned and he was only in
jail for being my brother and then I
come out and there's other people oh
they sent me a piece of paper blah blah
blah you're moaning it's unbelievable
you truly learn like I said jail
confirms everything you already knew
about the world and you truly learn
who's on your side and who isn't and
that's good to learn but
it's it's actually crazy the also the
the larger psychological analysis of it
all everyone lives inside their own
minds right so it's kind of crazy I came
out of jail
and some of the first messages I got
from people was them complaining about
the problems me being in jail had given
like
you think that wouldn't happen right you
think oh you come out of jail people
will be like oh are you okay they're
like oh you're okay you're out now okay
yeah well listen
you'd be amazed you'd be amazed and I'm
like I was in jail what do you want me
to do yeah that sounds unfortunate I was
in your jail cell what do you want me to
do about it it's kind of crazy how much
everyone's kind of self-interested so
it's been a learning curve and you learn
a lot about a lot of different people
and your circle gets smaller and I think
that's probably one of the reasons God
put me in there to just learn a lot and
make my circle smaller when you had your
little fake news drama Scandal did some
people that you thought were your
friends turned on you during that time
oh yeah I freaking freaking
um like MTR or Melanie they're both like
yeah they both of them Melanie two is no
dog she's done with you I mean I don't
know I mean it was more like she just
left like a comment saying she's gonna
like burn my studio down and I was just
like um and I know it was weird
yeah I mean she didn't make a video or
anything so it's like fine I'm not I'm
not really mad with her but it's like
but is this woman like 40. I I
don't know this is awesome daughters
Carson's a crime wow I don't know I
don't know but but it's like no but it's
weird because they were just there like
a week before and so I was just like
what are you guys doing like and like
then they're the then you know MTR made
the hit piece and I'm like you were just
here what
um and then what was the other one and
but it's like feminine Behavior like you
expect that from chicks yeah you know
what I mean like like you're telling me
like social of course I mean just
because she's 40. it's like she's still
a woman right but it's like I gave her a
benefit of the doubt she said some
things that are pretty smart but that's
pretty dumb to say I'm gonna
burn you that's a chocolate oh yeah I'm
not it's it's not I I really don't have
smoke with Melody but it was again at
the end of the day it's like
I I don't know they were just there we
had such a good time and then they make
a hit piece on me because of a media
circus of a video they didn't even watch
that was the crazy thing was neither of
them watched the video and they made and
they admitted that and then made a whole
hit piece on me and then on top of that
there were yeah I don't know anybody
else I'm trying to remember I feel like
there was like one or two more but I
don't even remember now I'm just glad
that this is my little fake Scandal
happened to me by a bunch of like small
people and not like a gigantic presence
because by oh yeah I guess Abba Abba and
pre they went one for you too didn't
they yeah yeah they did they did and
then but the the the thing that was
happened though is like I'm glad because
you know they're small channel two
million subscribers and like a dying
Channel like how off how long are people
gonna sit around and be like fake
offended by everything that they these
pseudo-moral police are doing but I'm
glad it happened because I'm still at an
early stage in my YouTube tube career
because I'm going to take my channel to
a million there's no doubt and I'm just
glad it happened now because a lot of
people in my like some people made a
circle
they're so mentally weak they're like oh
well you know
I saw this and I saw that and I don't
know if I could support you I'm like
you're didn't even call me didn't say
like what's your side of the story can
you give me some explanation just
immediately turned on me and honestly
when that happens now
I'm just like okay peace see you later
you know what the crazy thing was was
the one of the people that made a hit
piece on me I spoke to them on the phone
and you know he said he understood what
I was set like in the video he's like oh
no that makes sense I get it they're
just overblowing it and then it was like
oh like I need to stop the bleeding like
like basically like the audience was too
on his neck so yes but that's what
they're doing they just appease the
audience they just follow the audience
but yes bro you know it's I'm like over
it now but I'm glad it was just it just
honestly like it's like when you dated a
really really crazy girl right your
crazy detector gets like really refined
and so now I got spot crazy from a mile
away and then now I you know I have a
good heart I thought these people were
decent individuals but I got snaked by a
lot of dirty low IQ people well that's
why when you have people leaking group
chat messages oh my God
like it's like I don't remember what
yours was but I just I remember you said
something about it like a group chat or
something like one of the things they're
like trying to believe moral police was
like I saw like a very fat ugly girl and
I was like how should we kill this chick
it was clearly a joke right I'm not like
planning out
an awful video and watch the full
context but all these reaction channels
will take a clip and pull out of
context and and it's funny too like the
person that leaked the messages
this guy was a thousand times worse than
me and everything he said a thousand
times but that's what these people do
they're Liars they're manipulators you
know what they did to blessing
oh my gosh they freaking they did this
reaction where blessing was reading a
super chat but and it was like it was
making fun of um one of the people that
was here right that made a hit piece on
and basically they were painting it like
blessing said it uh but he didn't know
the context of the Super Chat because he
doesn't watch the space
and that's the crazy thing and I was
like you at the time blessing really
didn't want to be on camera and I'm like
so you're drawing attention to my
producer who you know doesn't want to be
on camera yeah and you know the context
because you watch I'm sure you watched
the full thing but it's like I don't
know it's just and that's right it's
dishonest no that's what I said all this
is for these people who are pretending
to be these moral Arbiters of Truth and
Justice all they're doing is lying
and manipulating to make money that's
all they're doing a lot I mean how many
times have impeachment been busted for
like blatant lives of manipulation
lies manipulation oh my gosh do you know
what they did I tell you the the what
they did with the obese thing and I tell
you they said I lied about uh an obesity
stat
and then when I quote it's like and then
I I gave them the link to the stat that
I was quoting and now that all they do
to their channels is just say oh she
just makes things up she just lies she
just lies and I'm like I know you saw
the stat I I'm a hundred percent
positive you saw it there they they said
they said this about me okay it's a
total lie they said that I got rejected
by a Japanese girl in an iclub so I took
a champagne bottle and broke it over her
face do you understand how hard you
would need to hit somebody with a
champagne bottle to break it that that
chick would be dead yeah and as racist
as the Japanese are I would be all over
the Japanese news right and
in prison you're not gonna be like oh
like you got to pay a fine you'll be on
your way like no a such a heinous crime
would absolutely demand of an American
which they hate us to be put into prison
yeah you know so it's just like when you
think but you don't nobody stops to
think nobody stops to understand content
and the thing is like when you're
watching a video you don't understand
how weird it is in real life to be like
doing these things yeah but like do you
know what I mean it's like I forgot
where did I get this like he's like
where did I get the shoes reaction
channels I was like oh I question your
morals I was just thinking like do you
know how weird that is in like real life
like imagine like as a grown grown ass
dude being like Oh I question your moral
like I'm like it's so odd it's just
anytime Behavior anytime I see a man use
the word
misogyny or misogynist I know I cannot
trust that guy that guy is a Garen
teed snake and I can't trust him
very it's just especially the drama
channels it's so feminine I just can't
imagine being like in their old old
people old people
I call them the gossip girls like just
sitting around oh that's all they're
doing sitting around gossiping gossiping
like what are you doing like what value
are you adding to your filthy audience
yeah but they're just they're just crazy
you just have to listen to them and pay
attention to it and say okay right
you're off you're off you're off you're
on you're on your own but my brother I
have to give him credit because I tell
you I also think me and Tristan one of
the best teams in the world because we
have different roles inside of our
Brotherhood
my role is to be concerned
and to panic not panic that's the wrong
word I never Panic my role is to be
concerned and try and fix the problem
I'm in jail pacing up and down how do we
get out
and Tristan's role is to not care and
together that helps us achieve the
objective best because when we really
need to get out I'm sorry there's a
super
um okay like how MLD and Destiny have
their views become to reasonable
conclusions logically thinking rather
than extreme minded people in the red
pill space
sometimes when it was when it was at the
height of frustration I needed his
superpower Tristan's superpower and this
is a superpower for life if he is the
master of not giving a we would go
to court we would go to court imagine
this you're in jail right weekends were
the worst because the TV was worse on
weekends for some reason like you had to
do like three channels at the TV the
weekends were the worst and you could
hear out the window everyone having fun
I hated weekends so on a Friday would
roll around I'd say Okay Tristan we just
have to Zen away the weekend and on
Monday There's Court we did to Zen away
the weekend so it's the weekend we just
sit there staring at the wall intrusive
thoughts can't sleep all those things
you're trying to get out your brain just
sitting in silence because the room's
tapped just staring at the wall just
staring at the wall and you think Monday
would never come and Monday would
eventually come right or Sunday night
comes and 8 A.M on Monday they're going
to take you to court and they might let
you go home they might let you go home
you've done nothing this person in this
room can decide if you go home and it's
Sunday night and you can't sleep and
you're awake all night long there's no
clock but you just you just the seconds
feel like hours you're just sitting
there eventually a am comes put you in
handcuffs walk you to the court you walk
in there everyone speaks Romanian don't
have a clue what's going on everyone's
just talking at each other in Romanian
then they say you'll get the answer in
three hours go back to jail when I went
back to jail I was sitting in the room I
was like do I pack to go home no that's
too optimistic okay but you're nervous
you're like you're anxious am I going to
go home is it over do I get to go home I
called the lawyer do you have an answer
yet no no answer yet okay sitting there
I can barely sit still Tristan finishes
course walk straight into the room
it's a matrix attack it's I'm
going to sleep and went to bed
oh my God asleep
he just went straight to bed and then
when he woke up like six hours later
Matrix attack I'm like yeah you thought
so and just rolled back over didn't care
but it's perfect for a guy like you but
that's what you need I need that I agree
if I had someone else next to me is
hyped as me I would have gone insane I
agree I need someone that came who's
just like he had the superpowers like
bro I love jail Jail's great look we got
coffee I love jail none of my women are
messaging me I love jail truth I may I
I'm telling you I had 45 minutes on the
phone a day and I used all of my minutes
Tristan never made a single phone call
from jail get added not one I was like
Tristan do you want to speak to anyone
nah
they're watching Romanian news they
didn't give a
like bulletproof but the only reason
he's so bulletproof that way is because
he knows I'm doing the absolute best the
other way he couldn't be that way if I
wasn't trying to get us out because then
he would try to get out you need the yin
and yang so like when I when I when it
was chill time it was his mental frame
and when it was attacked how do we get
out of here it was my mental frame but
Tristan's superpower genuinely is
genuinely genuinely not caring I can't
explain the level of how much he didn't
it didn't affect him he didn't bother
him at all I didn't see him sad
not that you smiling it didn't care you
consider yourself a stoic how much more
stoic is he than you I just think we
have different roles and I think we've
evolved into them over the time because
it's not just jails with everything
that's what we are with everything if
there's a business problem I'm the one
who's like we have to fix this now
and Tristan's the one like
Andrew you are so ridiculously Rich
chill
but we need that we need both right but
he couldn't be that chilled if I wasn't
the way I was because he wouldn't be
successful totally see you need the
opposite so everyone goes oh you your
brother yourself we're so close because
we're actually very let me ask you
questions like because you know
Tristan's very level-headed in this
situation right
the biggest thing that these people can
do to you your your detractors right is
to delete your YouTube channel and now
you've been deleted and you've been
canceled
[Music]
what what would you do after that do you
think like
do you think you could bounce back or do
you think it would be the end of you
like what is this big gotcha they're
trying to pull off
um what would I do
you think you would just Sail Away into
poverty and you know live under a bridge
I'd probably try Rumble maybe yeah I'd
probably go to rumble
um I mean Rumble is a viable option I
should just go home yeah
managing Talent like I think that's fun
right I mean you can act as a consultant
for sure yeah yeah I don't know what I'd
do I just kind of take my I don't really
worry about problems till they happen
yeah I don't I don't know if it's a
smart way to live you probably should
have some foresight but I just kind of
someone said I've worked on numerous
successful political campaigns ranging
from state representatives to goober
national race the red pill needs a
political arm that can swing back
against the opposition's narratives yeah
I think that's true I think it'd be but
I think it's tough
but I think I think it would actually be
good if we had some sort of like
Collective like lobbying you know for
men's yeah I just think that this is a
this is a temporary thing these are the
like the red pill has become
trendy the red pill has become big
enough they just can't ignore it anymore
and who are our biggest detractors like
a bisexual cuckold and two dudes who
make videos in their rooms in Canada
that's that's our biggest detractors you
know it's it's like what what do we have
to hear no I think he's saying like I
think he's like I'm saying it would be
good for us to create something that
like Works towards like like father's
rights like like having more fair
divorce laws like that sort of thing
didn't the lead attorney say that the
divorce laws are changing slowly
and I mean there's not the it's only
like 10 states I think have automatic 50
50 custody so I guess it's better than
zero I mean yeah like just how he's
saying incremental wins we get
incremental wins on our side too you
know and I think this too like female
treachery the great thing about like
smartphones and security cameras and
stuff like this like female treachery
like remember like 10 years ago
everybody would be believed sugar and
spice and all things nice you know but
now dudes a lot of dudes looking at a
woman with a side eye like
what's this up to yeah
I can't hear it King
even oh okay afterwards it's a lot
I still struggle to sleep he sleeps fine
because I think my experience of jail
was a far more stressful one because I
but I adopted that now I'm not saying I
couldn't have done what Tristan did I
could have done what Tristan did if I
were to go into jail and say your MO is
to not care I could not care but my Mo
was how do I get out of this Matrix
attack so I I was the most stressed I've
ever been in my life so that's carried
over so I don't sleep he sleeps fine but
he slept fine in jail so why wouldn't
you sleep fine now right so yeah it was
uh it was interesting but I have to give
him props because it's it's amazing to
have that level of clarity and he said
things which were absolutely not really
true things I already knew but it was
nice to hear I want to ask you a
question about this so I have two boys
right and one that they're going to
watch is they're not going to watch it
right now they're 11 nine but they're
one they're gonna watch this right uh
and in school you know I'll go and the
kids that are you know 11 12 13 they're
like you you Andrew Tate you know how
was that interview oh my God so 11 year
old kids are watching these types of
content about it that's pretty wild
where they're at but here's a question
about brothers
there's a lot of brothers out there as a
father there are certain principles I'm
teaching them okay one if you can speak
from the idea of how your bond was built
based on a man your father memory
injecting certain values and principles
into two of you yeah you guys better do
this I don't want to see this yeah and
then which part of the code did you guys
create because there's friendship but
there's Brotherhood there's a very
different story absolutely how was that
developed yeah so my father and I have
endless stories about my father a lot of
people who dislike me would call them an
extremist I don't think he was an
extremist I truly believe I had the best
father on the planet
and from a very young age he made it
clear he said look you're Tate and
you're gonna have animation of people
who are against you your best bet is to
be a team so whenever me and Tristan
would fight which happened we got put in
a room together
and we had to sit in that room and my
dad would say three hours or four hours
in silence
sit us down in the room here here
looking at each other and say if I hear
a noise I'm starting the time again
and we'd have to just imagine you know
you're a kid and you fight and you're
Furious and you're so mad and then you
end up sitting across from the person
you hate
silent because you make a noise dad gets
mad and Dad's outside right so just sit
there two hours don't make a noise
you need to stare at each other and over
time we thought every time dad was home
we just stopped fighting because it
wasn't worth it sitting in this
isolation weird silent stare thing
because that's what happened don't
repeat it happened like five times that
we just stopped fighting we
so we became a team and then I think it
evolved from there because there's
always been a hierarchy I am the older
brother I'm the bigger brother he does
respect me for that we both have
opinions but you know it can be it can
be vetoed by me in the end and we have
our specific roles my specific role is
I'm I'm the one who takes the most
action I'm the one who over worries I
believe especially in business and many
other things I say it to all my staff I
say react I said react fast react early
I panic early like Panic now
I don't believe in waiting for things
it's just not who I am I can give you a
million different examples if if my
email processor just happened
to perform a cancellation said oh we'll
put your account under review you'll
have an answer in 72 hours as soon as I
get that email within three minutes I'm
like get a new one get a new one I've
never waited for anything in my life and
it worked I've never waited and it
worked out fine Ever every time it
should cancel every time I should delete
it every time someone like I'll get a
new one now get just get a new one I
need today's email I'll get a new one we
can't get into one don't accept us build
one
like I'm the Panic fast and early guy
Tristan's the complete opposite and that
makes us a perfect Synergy and I I super
need him and I need his energy
especially in jail man he was fantastic
in jail he was like Andrew well they won
he goes if when you were 18 they told
you you could be one of the richest most
famous men on Earth
with street cred in every single City
that knows how to speak English all you
had to do was sit in jail for two months
would you have taken it it's like yeah
he goes what the do you care for
he goes I know he says that what kind of
man hasn't been to jail
and his energy was amazing to tap into
but we both understand that we neither
of us could be us without the other ones
polar and that's why we live together
that's why we'll always live together
I've had a lot of like women try and say
why do you still live with your brother
why do you want to live with me and I
try to explain to them that
one I don't think I can be my most
competitive without him
two I'm most emotionally stable with him
I like the idea I'm most competitive
with him I I'm my best version of me if
it doesn't matter I have to go into a
fight doesn't matter if I have to run a
business I'm better with Tristan by my
side than I would be by myself and three
my ideal family life even my ideal
family the way I live my life now is
very much more like a clan than a
nuclear family I like me my girl my kids
Tristan his girl his kids my cousin his
girl his kids I like this idea of lots
of people I like that I like that
feeling so girl say to me
you know my parents bought a
neighborhood for my my family so we
could do that
that's nice yeah so it's like we each
get a plot of land when we get married
really yeah in Chicago yeah and so yeah
that's why it's funny he's saying that
I'm like that's how my mom wants it to
be you know I think down the street like
they bought this neighborhood in like
2007 before the market crashed and then
they ended up not selling it because it
was like worthless for a while and then
they just end up keeping it you know I
get so when they say what do you bring
to the table I'm gonna be like seven
acres well you know what's funny too
like because I'm looking at the state of
London and I've had I've I've talked to
people in like Orlando and Miami and a
lot of people too like
what they want is what the Tates are
talking about they want a family they
want a clan of people that they can
trust and especially like when you get
to our level of you know you know
whatever Fame and success
it's really hard to trust new people no
it is super hard to trust young people
yeah and I don't want to trust new
people especially after like this
popping off viral twice in a row my last
two tours I do not want to meet anybody
new like I understand why uh Zuckerberg
like when he popped off and got famous
he went to his Chinese ex-girlfriend was
like Hey listen
Let's Get Married yeah because is that
what happened yeah yeah yeah
oh wow because he he got super super
popular and famous and then I think he
had broken up with that girl or he
either he had her and he married her it
was something like that but he locked
her down because God I mean to imagine
if we were Zuckerberg level famous and
yeah right but a lot of people that I
talk to and it's funny that I talk to
these people from different corners of
the earth and they're saying like you
know
I feel like I am a slave and trapped in
London I feel like I'm a slave and
trapped in Orlando because they tout
this big thing like oh just get this job
just get this you know college degree
just do this and then you're going to be
free but the reality is opposite even
like girls who do only fans right you
make all this money and what you do you
buy a bunch of that costs a lot of
money and then you have to stay a slave
to your job or only fans to keep up with
the quality of life that you're living
you know what I mean like your expensive
rent your expensive car all these things
and a lot of people have told me like
they feel like slaves in these cities
well and it's like they don't focus on
what's important yes you know what I
mean it's like I I know you know
obviously for a couple years you have to
cry and like figure your stuff out for
sure it's like at the end of the day
your family and relationships are what's
important and so many times we forget
about the relationships around us yeah
when like and that's the thing like
someone could have an average job but be
close with his family and be happier
than a rich man I truly believe that oh
absolutely no I mean they talk about
this studies that verify this like the
quality of your life and how long you
live and your happiness is directly
correlated to the relationships that you
have and the quality of relationships
not just relationships like sexual sense
but friendships families that that's a
direct correlation to how long you live
how happy you are and even how much
money you make you know what I mean so I
mean yeah sometimes I think about it too
like like now that I'm like you know
like my Uber driver noticed me today um
I'm like I wasn't like hey you know who
I am he's like hey I know who you are
um I really don't like it I really don't
like it I liked having my like little
insane corner of the internet where I
could just say whatever I could to my
Niche audience but now I'm like a
globally known figure and
um
you know there's a certain part of your
privacy that's like permanently stripped
and you and you know what you always
have to do you always have to like keep
one eye open you always like kind of
watching your back like what is this
motherfucker's angle you know what I
mean and I think the real things that
make you happy like I would I would bet
right now that the happiest moments in
your life are not related to money
that's true you know same thing here and
it's funny when you get all the money
um Jim Carrey said this and at one point
I I was just like man you Jim
Carrey but he was like I wish everybody
could get money
Fame and success so they could realize
how much it doesn't matter you know that
triggers a lot of people because a lot
of people think they because I think now
more than ever two people want to be
famous now more than ever yeah but I
wonder when you get money Fame and
success it's like you see who turns so
at the same time it's like
that's that's the thing it's like and
it's really hurtful to be honest because
you're like I don't know yeah
because you project your goodness onto
people and you like hope that they're
good and then you see they're evil and
you're like oh you and for me but like I
like I had you know dated people that
were just like I thought they were
something and I found out the truth
after and I just felt me personally I
felt dirty for like giving them a part
of myself to them I'm like ew you
treacherous like I gave
you like you spoke to my mom like you
know like you just feel like so like oh
betrayed by that and again going back to
the whole message of this all because
what men and women right men what are we
being telling these guys like oh get out
there get a Lambo get a Ferrari get all
this like get all these
materialistic things that at the end of
the day really do not matter what
matters is do you have a good loyal
trustworthy people in your life that got
your back no matter what because if you
don't have that than the quality of your
life is really in my opinion yeah I
agree you don't want a family like no I
want family bigger than you want I just
don't want to just sit with you I want a
lot of people around me and I think it's
better for that and I think it's better
for the children especially also I think
they enjoy it more but yeah I've got the
best brother on the planet I truly do
and um this is why I'm saying some of
our Best Days of Our Lives are in jail I
was going to ask you that you guys live
here in this compound it's amazing place
I was going to ask you you kind of just
answered it but you foresee yourself
living with your brother the rest of
your life a thousand percent
thousand percent I can't imagine not
wanting to live with Tristan if you want
privacy you have privacy right we have a
big house
it is what it is but I can't imagine
him not being around if there's a
problem I just shout his name or I just
can't imagine it and and I know on my
best self also there's the overall the
overall
male competition the masculine
competition that exists between us
between all men so we live currently
here we've got me my brother my
brother's personal trainers here we got
camera guys here we've got War Room guys
here we've got loads of guys here but I
can give you a million examples there
was a record set a next story of a gym
and there's a stair machine and there
was a record set of 188 floors within a
time frame I came along and smashed it
with 198. I only held the record for 45
minutes because someone beat it with
202. as soon as the record's beat and
everyone gets pissed off and puts their
trainers on puts her shoes on as soon as
it's beaten everyone gets mad who beat
it who beat it and and everyone goes and
did it and that's how you push yourself
to the level you never thought you'd be
able to push yourself 202 202 floors in
30 minutes good luck 200 no no no he
that's what that was
that was the beating again I don't know
if I'll ever get to that but I'm still
198 I gotta try again but the point is
when you have men around you there's
that natural masculine competition and
that's what drives you if you're going
to be the best version of yourself even
if you're a boxer training for a fight
you train with a team
you train with other boxers you train
with other boxers or other trainers
if you're a football if you're on a
football team you're pushed by your team
I think life should be the same right if
imagine you took the normal average man
and you moved him into a house of five
people and you had a philosopher and uh
Fitness expert and uh hypnotist whatever
it was
these will be that will make him a more
competitive person overall because he's
trying to compete with all the other
people who are on his level you don't
want to take position
so I I don't like the idea of my life
without masculine competition that's
what I'll always listen to my brother
and if you met a girl one day who says
Tay I want to have have your babies live
with you but it's kind of weird that
your brother's here what would you say
to her yeah a few of them have said that
I offer some degree of compromise I'm
like look we can have our own house
separate if you really want but I'm
gonna be spending a lot of time at that
other house including nights over I want
to stay with where my brother is so you
wouldn't compromise a little bit but
he's going to be living next door or
with you 100 and I don't think and that
may be unusual in the Western World I
don't think that's right he has a
daughter they said right he has he just
said here he has multiple children him
and Tristan have multiple children is it
do you know did they say if it's with
the same person or
them both have children no no no I meant
like like Tate like Andrew uh I'm just
wondering like does he not live with the
girls even when even like when they're
they have kids and stuff I think because
he's Muslim he has oh separate houses
multiple wives with multiple children I
mean Tate is uh Super Rich he can handle
that yeah no I was just wondering if you
if it's just him and his brother they
have their families with them how do you
feel about that what which part like
would you would you be down to be one of
many wives nah I can't do that yeah no I
think that's something that a lot of
guys I think because a lot of people
watch Andrew Tate and stuff I think
that's one thing that a lot of these
guys are pushing that really is just a
non-negotiable for the average woman
yeah like forcing like you must accept
other women no matter what yeah I think
I could
what I don't know does it hurt me but a
whole wife with another kid nah that's
too far I could like yeah I just don't I
don't think I and I think a lot of guys
pushing that message are causing men who
are in good relationships with good
women to lose good women because a good
woman is not gonna like a decent woman
with silver stack respect she's not
gonna tolerate that she's not like yeah
I'm just gonna
tolerate having another woman around you
know what I mean you have to have a
load of Leverage which means you got to
be really rich and have a lot of status
to pull that off and I just think that's
a message that it's just gonna
it's gonna ruin more dudes and their
happiness than bring happiness to those
men the few few men who could pull it
off and a lot of the times too I noticed
that these women who accept this is not
saying anything about the Tate's wives
or anything but like a lot of these
women who do accept this kind of like
okay I'll be
one of your many one I feel like she
doesn't love him as much like a part of
hers kept back and reserved and two a
lot of those women are kind of you know
the eggs are a little bit scrambled
they're not oh really I don't know I
don't know any girls that are like in
multiple wives relationships like that
sort of I don't know any yeah no I agree
with you on that I'm just saying like I
just think that this whole thing like
guys like I'm a high value oh actually I
do know one girl that wants a second
like she wants her boyfriend or like she
wants to get married not State what but
she's mus Muslims okay religion aside if
you're Muslim I understand because
that's a that's a according to your
religious text right which is a solid
selling point for Islam by the way yeah
yeah so as a man I gotta tell you that's
a solid a solid selling point right
um but outside of that I just think the
normal kind of regular girl is not gonna
do that like how much money would the
guy need to make for you to tolerate
that I mean you already well it's sorted
well that's not true I mean but you're
doing okay yeah I think just coming from
where I like come from I always know my
like my dad would take me home yeah you
know so I I just think and I'm just not
really a materialistic person so it's
just a hard no for you yeah it's just
like I
think maybe
if I grew up like lower class or
whatever but it's like I kind of have
everything I really want like what if
Andrew Tate want to take you on as his
multiple wives
um it's just not doing my thing well
because my dad's approval is really
important to me as it should be yeah and
so you know I once broke up with a guy
because I was dating him and my dad was
just like what do you like torture what
are you doing that's what he said to me
yeah yeah yeah
what what are you like do you he's like
do you like torture why what was
happening well I was just like crying
about something like I was just like
upset I mean I I you know I don't really
want to go into it too but my dad was
just like what are you you know and it
was funny he told me one of the most
profound things I think I told you this
once where I was like Dad like do you do
people change oh you know as a Woman
They want to change like do people
change my dad's like yeah they do they
do change
they get worse over time yeah they do it
so whatever he's like so whatever bad
trait you see for the most part
yeah it just gets worse in 10 years in
2015 I was 29 still a young man at that
time and I was dating a girl that like
she liked to drink almost every day
and I thought I could save her I thought
it could help her right and
to this day she has become like such a
massive alcoholic she's got like one
foot in the grave wow you know and it's
spot on like the amount of work like for
example me like I came from literal
abject poverty like didn't my mom didn't
have five dollars to give me for lunch
like growing up per day which didn't
have five dollars
uh we didn't have three dollars right
because I remember Chick-fil-A
sandwiches two or two dollars and fifty
cents and if I could like scrounge up
two dollars and fifty cents you know
between 2002 and 2004 when I graduated
from high school it was like the
highlight of my year my best friend
Jordan used to give me money because he
came from a rich family and he would
give me money and like I would always
get these Chick-fil-A sandwiches and was
so good and
you know growing up in that
crazy like poverty situation
um it really just gives you a whole
different perspective on like
in my opinion how
just modern people are just
so so and so entitled over the littlest
littlest littlest things compared to you
know just
simple happiness of just being able to
buy lunch you know what I mean so I mean
I don't know just looking at this whole
picture of these things nowadays I feel
like I watch my friend is in the
Philippines right now and he just put
out a video and he like went into like
the Philippine ghettos
and
it was like a family of like eight
like living in like this tin Hut wow and
they were so happy and they're like yeah
we just got to be happy because we have
family and that's all that matters in
life four of them are sleeping in like a
like a tattered cotton bed
and
it just like makes you look at
everything we have in the west
everything we have here and we have all
this materialistic stuff and everybody's
so isolated miserable alone and that
turns into like hate and like you know
like they perform these hate mobs and
like they're just trying to tear
everybody down it's just like so it's so
crazy how we have so much and yet we
have the most important things wrong
[Music]
welcome Amina
welcome to the just probably things gang
um
I actually noticed the same thing when I
did I went to India a couple years ago
really yeah it's funny I grew up like
traveling the world with my family you
know so we would go to like like before
I was 18 I went to like or I think by
the time I was 18 I went to India
Germany Japan like I've Been Everywhere
cool and
um one when I went to India that's what
I noticed too it was the most like
poverty I'd ever seen in my life but
they were really really happy yeah oh
yeah really really happy and I was like
they're almost happier in like the
non-western world some not always but
sometimes like with nothing than we are
where it's like yeah we're so spoiled
and especially we got especially young
people we're so spoiled I know and we
think oh I'm such a loser I only have
the iPhone 13. yeah yeah I know
I know
you talk about this all the time you
don't even know how much I love that
yeah I love that to me as a kid that was
a dream like if you could you know right
next to each other uh live like there's
a family in our community
uh billionaire family they live right
next to each other the the oldest son
has the biggest house 12 000 square feet
then the youngest son has the second
biggest house eight thousand square feet
and the parents live in the six thousand
square foot house right next to me
absolutely okay the two boys have four
kids the eight kids are always together
absolutely what a great environment
absolutely it's a dream environment
absolutely I I can't see how a person
wouldn't buy into that the benefits of
it and and there's also benefits to the
relationship because I I think you have
a better relationship with your woman if
she can go and talk with other women and
be with women and I'm with guys and then
you're together sometimes and you can
split it out I think it's better for
everybody
this whole idea of the of just man woman
Boom Child bang I understand where it's
come from I'm not saying it's all
typically bad but I do think that in
those scenarios there's a lot of men who
are particularly miserable particularly
men especially and the idea of a clan
and having that team around you I love
that I wouldn't live any other way I
love living that way well being born and
raised in Miami there's a lot of Latin
culture there yeah and you know the
American friends
they just move out move on their own
that's what they do but in Latin culture
the abuela is living in the house that
families living in there the the women
are all kind of congregated together I
like that we can also discuss it
financially right if if you're a man and
a woman and you have three boys and
they're let's say traditional Western
whatever they all go and pay three
different rents and they all move in
with their girlfriends and everyone's
getting wrecked right if you all stay
together and combine your income you
also do much better financially there's
not a lot of immigrants even survived
especially Muslim immigrants in England
yeah I've heard you tell the story about
it absolutely yeah they all stay
together in one big house they all pool
their incomes you have a bunch of people
with average jobs and Ferraris on the
drive and then they buy the house
they're in then they buy another you
pull the incomes if you all split and
separate and just spread out you're just
paying all different rents all different
electricity bills and you just go broke
you have to think of the last name and
the generation and the clan
that's and that's why I think marriage
married households like you know when
they stick together they're able to
achieve more financially as well because
you know you're splitting the burden of
everything like even in the Bible it
says it's better than China to the girl
on this show I mean if she was young but
I was like if you want to marry him like
I don't see why you don't just get
married now well listen my vibe was
maybe she didn't want to that was my
guess well yeah
did you take a look at her Instagram oh
I didn't know I didn't see it
well she you know is she advertising
yeah I got the vibe I got the vibe she
was kind of waiting for the next best
thing that was my vibe I didn't get that
Vibe maybe I'm dumb and I I bought her
at face value but when I saw her
Instagram I was like it was the top
because it's like it was a bit attention
like that I just the red hair I was just
like I don't know but but that's what I
was saying I was like you know if you
like him you know there's nothing wrong
with getting married young and it's a
lot easier to plan your life out that
way yeah no the uh her Instagram in my
it was a little Haram for me it was a
little Haram for me yeah I I could have
guessed I love the idea I live with my
brother I'll never live without him and
yeah his woman can move in of course his
kids can be around me of course I'm
Uncle why not I have no problem with
that that's a dream let's let's
transition to a couple other topics so
um
I saw a video by the president of
Microsoft Brandon I think it was the
president of Microsoft who said you're
going to see one of the biggest threats
in the future being deep fakes okay and
then you saw a similar thing being said
by Google Sergey Brennan you're gonna
see what's gonna happen with deep fakes
and then the example of deep fakes was
given by the actress from Wonder Woman
what's her name uh Gal Gadot
right there was a deep fake porn made up
her then it was a deep fake video made
of trump then there's deep fake of Joe
Rogan there's one of Morgan Freeman hi I
am not Morgan Freeman kind of goes like
this wow so the direction we're going
with deep fake right
when it comes down to AI where do you
see the threat is that something you you
think about is that something you see as
an opportunity as a threat and if yes
which part of it yeah have you heard of
the new conspiracy theory they're doing
now what they're saying that AI is going
to get out of control there's going to
be a big Global deep fake event and
there's gonna be so much AI
impersonating people that we are going
to have to get some kind of like
internet ID to prove that we're real
people versus AI wow that's the new
thing that's happened I bet that will
happen I mean I bet there'll be a lot of
deep fakes I don't know if it'll be that
but maybe we'd have to see but the dub
the world economic forum is also they've
also put out a video talking about how
the next pandemic is going to be a cyber
pandemic when like the the power grids
are shut down and everything's shut down
oh wow and yeah because if you play the
game long like you look at what the
first round of you know the the global
cough situation
first things first you have everybody
working remote and you're pushing
everybody online and then next thing
what do you do you have a Cyber attack
and you you cut everybody off
online because you know if all these
digital communities digital income
digital currencies so so what what'll
wouldn't that be bad for them because
I'd imagine they have more control on us
through their phones wouldn't that be
bad they would but at the same time you
know if you imagine if the internet went
out for like two days
like imagine the internet went out and
your phone lines went out and you're
here in your apartment like how are you
gonna contact anybody
probably just take a train to the
airport and go home well the airplanes
wouldn't work the internet's down the
phone lines are down so you're right
I guess me and Ellie would be hanging
out at lock my doors
I'd come find you if I was here I'd
knock on the door I'd be like hey can I
get a security today just in case I kind
of like that would be fun for Nigerians
because in our country there's usually
no light a lot of time so oh really
really oh yeah the easy it will be easy
for me to to live in that kind of
situation to be fair we gotta we gotta
get this guy uh
I'll tell King to come over that's the
emergency plan if if the internet goes
out king yeah the phone might come out
come here and save Pearl be like I'll be
like King please he's a fighter he's
gonna protect you
like I don't know I don't know what to
do because I definitely have very little
survival skills very few really what's
your top Survivor skill okay I'll tell
you I know how to call for a man to help
okay okay that too that too I've used my
feminine wirelesses you know but but but
no number one I well this wouldn't work
in the city but if we were out in the
country or whatever I know how to make a
like a sort of like a four out of six
out of sticks okay yeah so like they
taught us at this Camp how to like so
like if you needed to build like
uh I don't know how to describe it but
almost like a TP thing okay I can make a
TP thing out of sticks you don't need
one in this apartment well okay you know
you said what's your biggest survival
skill yeah that wouldn't help me here
but I have one okay do you know how to
make butter
no it's pretty easy I learned how to
make butter this year I mean you just
take
heavy cream or excuse me just like uh
regular cream like liquid cream and you
just whisk it and you blend it like you
know like the the mixer oh you just do
it and eventually it separates and makes
buttermilk and butter oh I can make
cookies from scratch I don't know if
that'll help in the apocalypse but yeah
so if maybe you could negotiate with the
people yes yes I make really good like
from scratch cookies especially yeah
it's like a family recipe that's that's
my that's my bargaining power I wonder
during the Cyber attack that they're
gonna shut the power grid off
why can't I you know that wouldn't stop
the cookies I mean yeah because how are
you gonna cook them
power goes out all right you know no I
mean look we got this balcony out here
we can cook them outside I like the
optimism you know you know I'll tell you
my number one thing is I'm very
resourceful yeah I'm very resourceful I
think you are
um but yeah I'll probably just find a
guy yeah yeah King will save you King
Kong company I'll be like King are you
working today I'll be like the powers
out
he fakes are certainly Gonna Change the
World because what we're gonna have is
we're gonna have a post-truth society
and then the only way they're gonna be
able to tell you what's true or not is
some committee which decides what's true
and what to do fake and then they're
going to be in charge of the world and
then they're going to lie to you and
then you're really in trouble so that's
gonna be very interesting once you get
to the point where what did I say
earlier about not being able to trust
your own eyes they're going to take that
away from us soon then what then you're
really in trouble
um in regards to AI I think it has to be
adopted inside of my school hostage
University we teach AI with absolutely
everything a lot of the images we
generate even on my Twitter accounts all
Ai and what's actually scary about the
modern world is I don't consider myself
old I'm 36. but some of the children
children I call them children 17 18 year
olds inside of my Schoolhouse University
they're AI Wizards and they can do magic
with this stuff magic like they can
literally genuinely Andrew Tate on the
moon and the image is generated in
seconds like artists are going out of
business I thought AI would put truck
drivers out of business artists are
going out of business musicians are
going out of business it's kind of scary
I do like to think that with things like
AI there's always going to be some
degree of natural separation between the
men who are genuinely inventive and
killers and the men who are more
let me change the way I say that I think
if you're an exceptional person a truly
exceptional person you don't have to be
afraid of nearly anything
but you'll probably agree with this in
my experience in nearly every business
in the world can have 10 killers and
then you have a bunch who want the
paycheck they do their job
but I wouldn't say they're Killers you
understand and we live in a society for
a long time where I can even I didn't
even tell you now sometimes when I hire
I'll say to to my cousin or to my my CLL
say look either get one killer or three
normal people because that's the reality
that's the basic you need three people
to have to the job or you need one
killer to do the job and I think those
three people who have to their jobs
enough to not get fired they turn up
most on time but they're not really that
motivated those are the ones who have to
fear AI I think businesses in the near
in the medium term are going to become
killers and AI
I tell them now I have some some guys
who work for me on one particular
company and their sales staff I was
reading through the sales scripts The
Killers doing really well but the
average guys that said you're not doing
much better than chat GPT could do right
now I want to warn you that you're not
doing much better that I could replace
you with a machine today let alone them
five years from now for free you need to
be careful so I think it's just becoming
more and more competitive the idea that
you can just be Joe schmoe do your job
turn up I don't try that hard it's fine
I think that's all going to go out the
window because as the world becomes more
competitive as a company you have to
compete with your competitors and the
only way you're going to be able to do
that is just where do you cut the flat
fat where do you cut the flat when I see
AI pop it up and getting more and more
intelligent in the way it's talking that
doesn't scare me Bible Way with words if
I was Joe schmoe I'd be afraid this chat
GPT could probably text your girl better
than you can
you'd probably he'd probably get laid
faster it's a little advice for the guys
out there yeah just imagine AI for
dating apps it's gonna happen
they'll do better than you do so that's
scary you know that's hilarious I I
think that's what the the average man
really needs to struggle and I've been
saying this has been my message for a
very long time in all Realms I've said
for a very long time that life for the
average man is going to get harder and
harder it's becoming more and more
competitive you need to find more and
more ways to stand out and be unique and
the only way to really do those things
unfortunately as a man is to suffer and
that's one of the reasons I'm kind of
glad that God put me in jail because if
you look at anything that builds a man
into a man there's a degree of suffering
it's very hard to become a man and have
a man who's a respected and has stories
and is capable when he only had a nice
life and nice experiences It's usually
the things that made you guys read a
thousand likes we need a thousand five
hundred to open the chat
if you are usually the worst things that
happen to you so the demons I carry from
jail the fact that I can't sleep
the fact that I can't sleep I've had
girls say to me you can't sleep you need
to see a psychiatrist and I said
absolutely not I would be furious if a
psychiatrist walked in here and took my
demons from me I don't care if they
could fix me with a click they're mine
and they're bestowed to me by God and
they are mine to deal with and they're
mine to fix because that's how I become
a better version of me I would be
furious if someone took them away from
me I'm glad I can't sleep good I can
train endlessly that's why I'm bigger
than I've ever been I'll train every I'm
not going to waste a minute but all the
demons that have been given to me by God
and all the problems I've been given to
me my God are mine to fix I would never
ever allow anybody else to take them
from me I'd be furious if a psychologist
came in and said I could cure you I'd
say no thank you I will cure myself I
don't care if it takes 10 years I don't
care myself that's my job
and I know that when that's done I will
be more mentally resilient than I ever
would have been without you
that's the whole point of it right
so many men say I want to be the man but
they don't want to suffer they don't
want to fight and I don't understand why
because even if you look at a superhero
movie they tell you even in superhero
movies they make it very clear Batman's
parents died that's why he's Batman
all the bad things have to happen
there's no way to get there without the
bad things I get so many emails from
people complaining about their bad
things and I don't have time to reply to
any of them but if I could I'd say good
yeah good luck congratulations off you
go of course you broke your heart of
course you're sad of course you miss her
she's with me now that's life that's
part of it that's the only way you're
gonna get to that level of resilience
you can't become the man any other way
so yeah I I thank God for everything bad
that's ever happened to me and all the
demons and I I trust that he's not going
to give me anything I cannot in the end
decipher and deal with in the end I
think it's a puzzle
and you decipher it and you work out the
best way to deal with it and you
internalize the good parts and you
become a better and stronger and more
resilient person for it
so I have to thank God for every single
one of them well I mean you got to go
through to be the ship that's
basically what it is and by so by the
way what you're saying is not a
hypothetical you talk about being the
average man you see this play out on
dating apps these days have you seen
what's happened especially on Instagram
and on all the dating apps hinge
bumbling out there the top guys out
there are getting 90 of the women
whereas the bottom guys I think the
stats are a third of men under 30 have
not been laid in a year if being average
is not acceptable anymore at all it's
not acceptable anymore and it's not it's
not acceptable in the sexual Marketplace
but it's also just not acceptable I
don't think even in life anymore period
I think that's it I think that's in the
west though because there's a lot of
countries where like average people are
still getting together this whole like
consumerism competition thing that's
happening in the west like what they're
saying right now it's not good it's not
good for anybody you know I think people
need to really understand their value
know their worth and just get in where
you fit in I think I think everybody's
over entitled nowadays what do you think
yeah I mean I I think it's coming though
I think what's coming like consumerism I
think it's going to come everywhere for
the most part I think I think social
media unless like I think China maybe it
won't as much much because like they're
very like they limit their social media
but I don't know I I I I I know you're
optimistic I think something has to
happen for things to get better
what has to happen I don't know but some
sort of like something to kind of like
humble the West
I don't know what well I mean the the
way we're going about it is not
sustainable right no it's not but I
think something I think something is
going to Humble us and then things will
start to get better I think that it's
it's how I look at people who took the
clot shot the dummies and what you know
I think that
Darwinism is going to play a role and I
think
the smart people the exceptional people
are gonna be okay and the ones who be
the victims are the dumb ones the ones
who trust the Matrix the ones who trust
the corporations the ones who foolishly
put their trust into these organizations
that people like you and I know don't
trust you know so I think that's
the big thing that's gonna happen so I
mean I'm I'm optimistic for myself
because right you know I really don't
need all this consumerism
that's going on right now like I've kind
of gone through my phase where I like
wanted to like buy expensive clothing
buy expensive stuff like right now I
really don't buy anything that's over
the top expensive I'm I'm spending my
money really on just like Investments
and then
vacations and stuff right memories
because you know I think a lot of people
too I think a lot of people nowadays
they really
don't internalize the fact that they're
going to permanently die one day they
they really a lot of people don't really
internalize that they live a life for
themselves yeah and when you live a life
that's why I tell my sister I say you
live a life for yourself if you be
selfish and you only focus on yourself
that's who you're going to end up with
well the richest people are the people
that have a ton of people that like
really love them at the end of their
life like I don't know anyone more loved
than my dad and it's because that is the
most selfless man that like on the
planet there's nobody like growing up
like people would be walking out of the
grocery store with like a bunch of bags
my dad would just like take them and
like put them in their car like he
wouldn't even know them he would like
same thing with like
um I don't know if they were like
carrying stuff like he helped people
move all the time and like even all of
us like he helps me with my business he
helps my brother like my whole life he
said his only goal in life was to pay
for all of our College
that's all he wanted to do was just pay
for everybody's College because he was
in debt in his early 20s he didn't want
us to go through that wow like and
that's the thing it's like you can tell
who has really lived a selfless life
because what do the people around them
say yeah absolutely yeah and you know
that that's the thing too this whole me
me culture like I said when you focus on
me me me when you focus on yourself only
you
you know like it's funny because they
all thought of like the Modern Woman
what do they want to be a strong
independent woman independent means
alone
it means by yourself and that's what
they're ending up with and they're like
I don't get it right what happened like
well you've been this strong
independent woman now you're strong and
you're independent and you're miserable
you know and I just hate that we I just
hate that they a lot I don't even care
if that's what they want to do but even
like denalova in the show yesterday I'm
like stop lying to the next generation
of women like it's not it's not cute
it's not fun and we all see it we all
see what you're doing
um because I just think it's an ego
investment like you're it takes a real
strong person to be like you know what
I was wrong yeah it takes a real strong
person and I think people are weaker now
more than ever you know but this to look
in the mirror because like when I turned
my entire life around I was 33 it just
turned over to 2019. everybody was you
know busted fireworks and eat food
having a good time and I had a
conversation with myself like dude you
are a
33 year old loser English teacher who's
talked all his you're an English
teacher oh I didn't know that in Japan I
was I don't know why okay and I was like
you're a 33 year old loser English
teacher and you talked all this
you're gonna do all this great
things in YouTube and you have put in a
fraction of the effort necessary to do
it and if you don't turn this around
this is your life you will be a 34 year
old English loser teacher you will be a
35 year old loser English teacher you'll
be 36 year old losing this teacher so
you better turn this franchise
around and that's when I bought like I
had like a little bit of Bitcoin left
over and I bought a computer I bought
because you can buy stuff with Bitcoin
in Japan and so I bought a computer I
bought a laptop I bought a a
microphone and a HD uh camera
and started live streaming and then I
turned my entire life around wow you
know that was that was the beginning of
like you know multi-million dollar
earning company and um but it all
started with me
being extremely real with myself being
being honest about the reality of where
I was you know and I think a lot of
people right now they don't I guess like
going back girl saying earlier a lot of
people just don't take accountability a
lot of people are just like no I'm great
I'm the best like I I'm they they lie to
themselves their friends lie to them you
know I mean how many girls stay single
because all their girlfriends lie to
them like oh it's never your fault girls
you know you just you gotta find the
right guy you know when I when I
finished
um playing sports in college
um I gained weight really fast because I
I just I was so used to bro like imagine
I've been I've been working out for four
hours a day right for I was I don't know
22 when I graduated college so or the
Masters thing so since I was 12 so for
10 years I didn't really have to eat
very good yeah you know who who needs to
and you're burning thousands like I
would do a two hour volleyball and two
hour bath football practice that is so
much a lot of calories yeah yeah and so
I I finished and I just ate like that
like normal right and I got a job and
then what happens is a lot of us get
really fat after because we just have no
nutrition skills yeah and it was funny
because I was at work
and all the guys were like making fun of
like they would never they didn't know I
was at the time but I was over like 200
pounds I was like 2 10. and that was it
was bad I gained it so fast dude I
wasn't that big for that long but I
didn't look that big because I'm so tall
right so but they were saying I would
never date a girl over 200 and that was
like the most I remember I'd weighed
myself that morning
and that was like and I just like I
didn't know I'd gained that much weight
and have you ever like weighed yourself
after yeah you're like you can't even
believe you're that heavy and so I was
just like no and I ended up like I ended
up losing a bunch of weight because of
it yeah
um and I'm glad that that was like a
wake-up call I'm glad there may I mean
it wasn't me they didn't know it was me
yeah but like I'm glad I had that
wake-up call yeah and a lot of people
would get on the scale and they'd be
like nah the scale is broken
I'd be like oh it's a bad angle in the
mirror you know but again taking
accountability taking responsibility and
just trying to do better living a life
of self-improvement I think it's just
the answer for everybody because again
like I told you yesterday like I don't
feel like the Earth is overpopulated I
feel like the Earth is undereducated and
I
don't know if this is true but I think
it is but I feel like people are getting
Dumber
oh yeah we have a whole generation of
people that don't know how to do things
yeah I mean like our great grandmothers
they knew how to sew they knew how to
all cook all these meals from scratch
and even on the guy's side like what
percent of guys know how to build a
house right our great grandfather is
like literally built their houses like
and I mean we have different skills
right like internet skills but it's just
interesting because there's a whole
generation of people that don't have
like basic life skills yeah well I mean
think about how many people have become
dependent on these apps to Live yeah I
mean even me like we're eats and all
that no even Me growing up I didn't cook
when was I gonna cook I went to practice
four out like you know what I mean so
you get out of school I don't know two
you wait an hour for practice to start
you do a two-hour practice and you drive
an hour do your other two hour practice
it's like 10 30 at night by the time I
get home when was I gonna cook yeah I
didn't have any time and so
um do you know how to cook now yeah I'm
pretty good I wouldn't say great but
like I I'm way better than I was like
two three years ago what's your what's
your go-to dish my favorite I like to
make sushi bowls okay so I I don't make
this that often but that's like my faith
I'm trying to like impress somebody
that's what there's no cooking involved
with sushi no no I I cook the salmon
okay and is that Sushi if you cook it
well it's like a poke Bowl okay pokey's
roll pokey's raw too well I guess it's
like a cheap poke Bowl okay I usually do
that I'll make cookies from scratch so
get some scratches good I'll do what
about a high protein low calorie
nutritious meal
um I like to make
I don't know drumsticks okay like
chicken in the air fryer sometimes I
like the oven that's my favorite ovens
are good yeah sometimes I'll do air
fryer if I'm in a hurry you know there's
in the average Chef Kings ate my food
King rate it one day I one to one to
five be honest
yeah five being the best yeah five being
the best
it's okay it's okay you can I used to be
like a zero so you could be honest
I'll say 3.5
see it's it's above average it's
improving it's above average I don't say
great but I'm like I'm getting better
where where is the chicken flawed King
yeah tell me how can I improve the
chicken no today's chicken was actually
very good though oh it's today's rating
I season it too much right that's my
problem that's what blessing says maybe
she just I'll just say you don't have
like a consistent
like Flavor so sometimes you go over
season it sometimes maybe not like yeah
maybe it depends on your mood I don't
know I like the honesty yeah why did you
cook me chicken
um because you weren't here when we were
eating dinner if you were here I want
dinner tomorrow
bye now so much to even protect yourself
the idea that you can just be a
law-abiding citizen in a country and
just work your job and be okay is gone
it's gone if Kobe doesn't prove that I
don't know what will yeah look at my
situation you have to diversify you have
to be smart enough that you have assets
and friends and and capability and
lawyers and whatever all over the world
now that's the only way to protect
yourself you can't just sit within one
jurisdiction and go oh well but I don't
speed so it's going to be okay I don't
think it is I think it's coming to a
point where it's not going to be okay
and AI is going to make it harder and
harder again for those average men it's
going to be harder and harder I don't
think the exceptional men are ever going
to suffer from me I think we're going to
use AI yeah I think this whole neural
link that Elon Musk just got the
approval for for the patent so now the
sale is going to be look no matter what
you do John you will never be like
Andrew Tate yeah but if yeah you take
care GT500
slash Tate you're able to get upgraded
to his levels and think like him and
I'll think can do this and do that for
only forty nine thousand dollars
to you my mother always says to me I'm
glad I'm not young and I'm starting to
say that now I'm glad I'm not young
because I'm telling you it's gonna be
scary right because the world is hyper
competitive every single thing in the
world is competition I don't think
people realize I'm a hyper-competitive
person because I understand that every
single thing I want somebody else wants
the girl I want other people want the
car I want other people want the house I
want other people want the lifestyle the
jet every single thing you want somebody
else wants it's a massive competition as
a man you have two choices you either
accept that as a massive competition and
try and play the game or you just try
and pretend it's not a competition and
Live In Perpetual failure
and it's going to become hyper
competitive the world already is you're
not gonna be able to compete with a
person with a computer brain so you're
gonna you're gonna have to have it
because you can't compete then once you
have it then who knows can they turn it
off I don't know can they turn you off I
don't know can they inject the slave
mind programming directly through the
chip I don't know that's scary you never
want to do that but it's going to get to
a point where you're not even a person
without it you can't function without it
you're a second class citizen without it
right what happens to competition then
is it going to be yeah or has access to
the best uh technology Whoever has the
most recent upgraded version of XYZ
neurology yeah what happens like
absolutely what happens if someone hacks
you
I don't know you know there there's a
are you familiar with the an old TV show
called The Outer Limits no so they had
this like future where everybody had
like these brain implants like neural
link right and there was like this one
guy and he was like the dummy of society
and he like couldn't really uh get the
implant because his brain was not
compatible so he was like the idiot of
society but like one by one everybody
who had that thing like started going
crazy and Society started to collapse
dude that's insane sometimes I think the
Amish had it right you know the Amish
are dude do you know how the Amish they
do have it right you know why because
they give their children money and stuff
and they're like go out there and they
go they party they do drugs they have
sex they do all the crazy stuff and
you're like a large percentage of them
just come back to the Amish lifestyle
you know life is simple and I think a
lot of people you know because I I think
a lot of guys in the red pill Community
think like they have like this infinite
wall that men have wall too you know I
call it the loser wall it's like if
you're a man after the age of like 35
and you really don't have your
sorted out like you up yeah you
up if you're still worrying about
money after age 35 if your career is not
really what you want it to be after the
age of 35 if you're just struggling
after the age of 35 your Fitness is
your your finances are your
relationships are like you have
truly up do you think there's
ever an age where it's like
it's too late for men to get married
like where the most quality women won't
be interested in them because they're
too old for sure absolutely there isn't
that men absolutely have a wall
um obviously not to the same extent like
as women but what age do you think it's
like I don't know maybe a 22 year old or
25 year old is just not even if he's
good looking not I think once you start
getting into your 40s
the the number the four at the beginning
your age is a turn off I think women
after 20 25 and after
they could
rationalize it especially like 29 28 but
yeah he's 40 but he's got his
together he takes care of himself his
dick works whatever right
um but girls 24 and younger
like having something long-term unless
you have like a lot of money and status
is gonna be
kind of hard because I think that's the
thing a lot of things that in the red
pill guys they they say that like all
your men have no wall but like you know
even in your 50s could you pull a chick
I mean even after you like even before
could you pull a woman like you know 21
22 23 24 yeah I mean literally Leonardo
DiCaprio's doing it but he's also
Leonardo DiCaprio I almost I'm trying to
think
I almost think for guys it's like after
45 yeah that's kind of the first number
I was thinking about it was 45 but I
would say like 40 it's like you're kind
of a little more hesitant like you're 26
right now yeah if a 40 year old guy was
like Hey I want to get married with you
and like lock you down and I want to
meet your dad I think 40 is okay you
could stomach 40. yeah as long as
there's no kids like I just um and this
is something like I I just would prefer
I've always just seen it where we just
both have no kids like I just really
want to give someone their first child
for sure so that's I know a lot of girls
don't care but that's just for me but
you're one of those rare girls with
standards yeah no well I mean I have
data to someone with a kid before but I
I just wouldn't do it again like yeah I
dated a single mom before and then it
was just not I was just like I I was
just it was a one and done thing like
you know will I
sleep with a single mom if she's
attractive
course
seriously date
it would it would have to I would have
to really get to know her and like I'll
there would have to be so many blatant
hard yeses in my face that make it very
hard for me to say no but like it's just
still because the thing is like then
you're always unless the guys like
ghosted on the kid well I just I just
think my dad like wouldn't really like
that that's always what I think of I'm
like I love how much your dad has has an
influence on you that's such a good
thing yeah like oh my gosh I went on a
date with a guy I really liked him too
like I really like I really liked him
but he told me he had a kid on it and I
was just like I just couldn't do it I
was just like yeah yeah I never saw him
again yeah because yeah because I just I
just know my dad just would not be like
did you how'd you break it off or you
just ghosted him no I just told him like
sorry you have a kid yeah I know I like
went home because I thought about it
because I think I was so cute but I like
just went home and I was just like no my
dad wouldn't like like because I don't
want to like do it like I don't really
want to like
spend more time with somebody if like
there's something yeah yeah I don't want
to waste either of our time so I know I
literally just like called him and just
told him what it was wow you didn't text
him good for you yeah you know good for
you yeah yeah you're definitely going to
heaven like I think the higher levels of
Heaven are waiting for you not not the
highest not the highest because you have
a dirty mouth yeah you know I am a big
SW I like enough bomb here over there I
Do I Do Don't Worry Allie's not gonna
get to the highest level of heaven with
you either yeah yeah you know and the
the tattoo sleeve you know oh yeah yeah
you have tattoos no not I was really
close to getting one when I was 18 not
because I wanted one I wanted my mom was
irritating me and I just wanted to get
one to make her mad oh no what are we
gonna get it was gonna be small it was
gonna be I think I was actually going to
get a dot in between my toes
I was just to say just to spite her yeah
I just
the females are so petty yeah you know
my you know it's funny my sister has
like a million tattoos I have I have a
blue-haired cyst like a I don't know she
says she's not a feminist but like
basically a blue-haired tattoo she has
all the symptoms of a feminist yeah
that's what I tell her I'm like how did
we come from the same house like look at
her she's actually really not she's like
a really sweet kid but it's just I don't
know the wokie her friends oh yeah
sometimes you can't even avoid it it's
the friends and in the dude people are
people really think they are so
impervious and these like you know these
non-influenceable people but like
whoever you spend time with is exactly
who you're gonna become yeah no you are
gonna become that I've had to like kind
of cut people off before because I'm
just like ah they're just they're being
a bit too wild I need to take a step
back from that because I just don't want
it to like influence me too much you
know oh yeah but
the
I wish Ellie got stuck outside she'll
figure it out she'll figure it out it
becomes scary I'm glad I'm not young I
hope it doesn't happen while I'm alive I
don't know it's going to be it's gonna
be an interesting world does it does it
inspire you want to have more kids or
are you like that's indifferent I'm
gonna have the kids I'm not worried
about that I think yeah I think they I
think in the 1700s they're probably
saying the same thing the future's over
and the Future Ain't that bad so
there'll be a way it will work out I
just have to instill within them the
same values I have and they'll find a
way to work it out and and hopefully
they'll be okay you always say the
future looks bright I mean you must be
concerned you've got kids I would have
to I'm with I'm with PVD on them I do
feel like that I don't know I don't I
just I think it's the low sorry this is
me just ranting but I just think it's
low hanging fruit intellectually to
think like we're all gonna end up in
FEMA camps and like the human race is
going to be enslaved like if AI takes
all the jobs then
who who's AI going to sell things to if
they don't have money yeah no they'll
figure something out you know like it's
not I mean I I think I think
you know what happened I I wonder if
maybe we would go back to quality over
quantity yes because I was wondering
like it's too much
but I was thinking growing up my my
family would always buy furniture from
the Amish oh wow really yeah and so
that's Chicago yeah well in Wisconsin we
would drive up there and get it I
thought all the Amish were just in
Pennsylvania am I oh no there's
Amish in Wisconsin and like uh rural
parts yeah wow yeah yeah there is there
totally is
um and the furniture is like good
quality great quality we had it my whole
like I think we moved into that house in
like third grade and we had the same
Furniture wow now I'm 26. still there
yeah same Furniture a lot of it yeah
that's cool
um no and you know you know what's funny
though um all the girls will talk about
like Farm Life on Instagram or they just
want to find a guy and go to a farm and
I'm like know yourself see that
swear I'm like I'm like these ladies
don't know themselves because I'm like I
I'm telling you I grew up on 40 acres I
did very minimal farm work and and I'm
and I I've seen what the Amish do you
don't even know like a fraction of the
work that goes into that stuff like at
all oh wow but I forgot where I was
going with this the before the farm
Amish growing up
I don't remember Wisconsin I lost it
all right now back to regular schedule
programs
if I could if I would have 20 more kids
right I don't know how you feel about it
I'd have 20 more kids right now oh
optimism yeah yeah no I remembered so I
I wonder if people will start to make
things that are quality again oh yeah
yeah yeah that's what people will pay
for so like everything's made in China
and breaks in like five days right and
so I wonder if like we'll go back to
like people that have to go back to
learning like actual skills versus like
online or sitting in an office because
their jobs will be replaced Justice or I
wonder if most of the jobs that are
being replaced do you know who they are
women's jobs
useless jobs no yeah yes I have like
maybe this will bring like women home
yeah right I do think there's going to
be an influx in women that go into like
entertainment yeah but I like I do think
maybe it'll eliminate women's jobs and
maybe we'll have like guys go back to
like qualities I was talking to Joe
Justin uh Justin Waller in Miami about a
year ago and we were all talking about
it and he's like right now the trend is
to like be a YouTuber be an entrepreneur
or all this right and majority of
these guys fail because they're just
chasing dreams that are not
really realistic everybody can't be a
entrepreneur right but he's
thinking like the new trend soon is
going to be like get a job in the trades
like dude do you know that there's a
massive shortage in plumbers in welders
in power linemen like all of these
trade-based jobs are starving and dying
for people to operate yeah I worked at a
have lived many lives I worked at a
plumbing tech company so we would sell
like plumber parts to like plumbers and
yeah they those guys made good money
they were they're happy people 300 an
hour yeah that's that's when I first
realized the difference between how men
and women talk because the way they
would talk to each other I was like I
was like oh gosh they're so mean we'll
give us some examples with your foul
mouth oh gosh I don't I
they were all going in on this one guy
I'm like it's okay like you're here I
was like why are you guys talking like
that that's just that's how men are yeah
and there would be like one or two girls
that were just like like they were just
boss like they were just like you could
just tell those women were tough because
they were the only like two girls in the
whole thing female plumbers yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely love children
there's nothing bad about having
children the only thing I wish I did to
start earlier
well listen right now I feel the same
way you know if you need some
inspiration there's this guy named Al
Pacino
where the kid at 82. I was 29 years old
and the Nero had it at 79. wow wow well
so it's never too late if you got the
testosterone level of 32 I'm sure you
can have 20 more kids I'll be okay
politics let's talk politics with uh
America you're seeing what's going on
with the election one of the uh Vantage
points you have is you're not there it's
kind of like it's your problem you guys
deal with it yeah I'm over here on this
side
from your perspective YouTube comes out
hey all the election stuff you guys
talked about that we would ban it and
take you down you guys can talk about it
now because we want a balanced argument
from both sides okay now
um it's because they don't want people
going to Twitter what are your thoughts
on the Trump today 2024 DeSantis Biden
how do you see this thing planning up
politics is is so interesting it's it's
so messy I mean obviously I'm a trump
supporter I believe in Trump I like the
scientists and the things he did
I I'm not going to choose between Trump
or DeSantis I think if one of them won
if any of them won it would be fantastic
for the world
I think YouTube taking a back step is
actually extremely important
symbolically yeah it'd be interesting to
see if they keep that up post this
election seeing what happens with this
election that'll be very interesting uh
but I think it's certainly a massive
symbolic step back I remember when I got
canceled nobody talked about Rumble
nobody talked about kick nobody talked
about even you got valuetainment no
disrespect you were a lot smaller than
you are now of course it's crazy how
fast Alternatives have popped up and I'm
only saying this because I do feel like
I literally said I remember my exact
words I said there's pressure behind the
dam everyone's tired of it all it takes
is a crack and when there's a crack
there'll be a flood and the crack in the
dam will be a man who is more famous
once he's canceled than he was before he
was canceled that's what I said now
they're trying to put me in jail which
is making me more famous again I'm not
saying it's all because of me but I'm
saying there's definitely a public
Consciousness switch where the the
arbitrars of Truth are having to
backstep now they've overused their
power they overstep their power exactly
we said they would and now they're
allowing open discourse so I hope the
America has a free and fair election
that's what I'm praying for I think
every country should have a free and
fair election especially when we're
gonna are you fly fighter jets and drop
fire are you in the camp of
not believing the Integrity of 2020 can
we even like what are the rules on that
I don't know but I don't all I know is
when I went to sleep we were winning and
when I woke up we were losing and it was
kind of weird yeah that's all I know
yeah like I I just think it's quite odd
that's never happened before in the
history I think I think it's weird under
a thousand dollar bombs on Farmers
who've never made five dollars in their
day and into the guys of democracy but
we're gonna bother to do that that we
should at least have a democracy
ourselves so I think a free and fair
election will be interesting and I think
the will of the people should be done
and that's how America was built and
founded and that's what I would like to
see and I do think that America does
lead the public Consciousness overall as
a whole I know what you're saying about
me being over here but I do think that
which which side wins does have an
overreaching effect overall on the world
on the planet I mean that's still the
most powerful country on Earth yeah it
would be very interesting to see what
happens in 2024 we'll put it that way
crazy question for you he gets
approached all the time pbd when you're
running when you run a DVD he goes I'll
vote for you bro yeah he goes listen I
was born in Iran made in America I can't
run why when are you gonna
well you were born in America
entertainment I was yeah you know you
were raised in Luton UK you lived in
Romania but you are an American citizen
I have no idea with me first I have no
idea president of the United States
Andrew Tate what would that look like I
have no idea what it'd be like to be
president but I have a feeling what
Putin said about the presidents might be
true did you ever see what Putin said
yes eight years they come and go yeah
I've been I've seen three presidents
I've seen a lot of presidents come and
go and they all come with these Grand
ideas but once they get in office the
people with the briefcases and the dark
Suits come in and sit them down because
of the strong bureaucracy inside of the
United States and explain to them how
things are done and they never seem to
get their ideas done they never seem to
do the things they said they were going
to do you include Trump enough
I think Trump tried his very best to
resist that and that's why he's in this
situation that's why they're taking him
to court for no reason that's why he was
Matrix attacked I mean if Trump's okay
let's let's cut the regardless I'm going
back to jail anyway probably this makes
your stuff going to try and kill me
anyway
they probably are if Trump's situation
isn't a matrix attack what is
what did they just hit with in New York
some deformation for defending himself
against a lie is that if that's not a
matrix attack tell me what what is
possibly else anyone who's sitting out
here who actually truly believes that
the Matrix doesn't exist has no idea how
the world works the media machine and
the legal system work hand in hand to
try and slander people's name and
convince you enough convince the
populist enough that they're guilty so
there's no Revolt so they can hit him
with a guilty plea they've already
decided before all of it it's all it's
all it's all a plan this many months of
negative news then we'll hit him with
this we'll get him guilty for this and
with this many months of negative news
the populists will probably swallow it
yeah it's garbage it's a matrix attack
from head to toe how much do you see
yourself in Trump and do you use your
words first they try to cancel you he
was canceled yeah then they try to throw
you in jail he's dealing with lawsuits
yeah lastly they try to put a bull in
there well Trump's lucky because he's a
bit older so Trump will try and Outlast
him they'll wait my problem is I'm a bit
young you know and I also think the
reason I feel particularly at risk and I
I say these things on podcast to protect
myself and I don't want anyone to think
I'm paranoid or crazy because I I really
don't believe I am the reason I think
I'm particularly at risk is for the
thing you just said it's the masculine
youth who are my fans it's the 11 year
olds 12 year olds 15 year olds 16 year
olds they are the future of the world
they're the people you want to go and
die in a ditch they're the soldiers you
need those are the people you need Psy
off do you need them psyopt you can't
have a bunch of men who aren't psyopt
that's when you lose control of
everything when the men don't listen
anymore
and they're all listening to me and I'm
teaching them things like God religion
personal responsibility accountability
discipline and everyone's saying well
why are they attacking Andrew for just
telling the truth making me go to the
gym because when you have these things
when you have accountability and
discipline and personal responsibility
you have a barrier you have a parameter
you have a no you have a limit they
don't want to have a limit none of the
men are allowed limits we must accept
whatever we are given from our
relationship with our woman from the
government from our job we're just the
slaves we're we're the backbone of the
tax bracket we just have to shut up and
pay our taxes as soon as we have limits
that they have a problem that's why they
dislike the things I teach and that was
like the biggest red pill moment for me
when I was like men are really not
allowed to have standards it's like they
cannot they can they can literally they
they can't want a fit woman they can't
want a friendly woman they can't want
their wife to sleep with them they can't
they can't complain when she leaves and
if she does leave it's his fault men
literally whenever they have a standard
they are shamed for it demonized
demonized and that's what's so great
about Tate is he's telling young men to
have standards he's warning them about
women and showing them how to navigate
like a good relationship too it's not
like he's all one-sided yeah
um but they just demonize him because he
does that I have a theory though about
women in the west and the Western World
in general and I honestly think
I think men will create an AI that can
emotionally satisfy them from a dating
perspective
faster
than women
collectively getting their together
I think they're not I really think it's
just a lost cause I think I think I
think a few exceptional men will find
the few exceptional women and they can
have these happy lives because that's
really what all life has to be you just
got to find somebody to have a happy
life with to be as happy as you can
before you die right and I just think
that dude these like these chicks are so
far gone like you know no no offense to
denelva but last night you were like
trying your damnedest to get through to
her with like objective facts and
objective reality yeah and she's an
educated woman she's smart enough to you
know talk well yeah but
you just weren't getting through to her
and a lot of these girls are stubborn my
sister is in her mid-30s right
mid 30s age 35.
and she still is going on the men ain't
and talking all this nonsense
all men are trash and not looking at
herself in the mirror and being like
what am I doing wrong
I met I talked to a woman
in her 40s who's good looking
and
talking to her
she doesn't even watch fresh and fit but
she sounds just like the fresh and fake
girls no like I'm holding out for what I
deserve like lady even hold it out for
half a century almost like Kane you're a
whole 40s like is he gonna push you down
the aisle in a wheelchair like you what
does this deserve like you don't deserve
the only thing that the only people that
deserve things are children yeah like
children deserve love but that nobody
else does yeah and so it's like if
you're 50 you've had zero takers
you said 40 so but like she's almost 50.
yeah zero takers yeah I know that's I
think 50's coming up next it's not like
you're gonna be four you're gonna go
into your 30s like you're only gonna get
older and the again are you trying to
talk to your sister I don't talk to her
anymore oh you don't talk to her anymore
she's just too far gone I tried I
brought my sister on a sneako stream I
saw a saver yeah it's too like when
they're too far gone you just have to
you know she's luckily young I have hope
yeah well I mean I I mean you know
Brandon Carter talks about this too like
one time he he had an argument with one
of his sisters and she yelled at him he
was like
why am I going to put up with this
right I'm Brandon Carter like
why am I gonna put up with this like I
am a guy who like as a one-man Army has
started a very successful business
completely by my own so why am I gonna
sit here and tolerate this from her
and let alone like these entitled chicks
that I date too but I mean even you know
it's it's it's even kind of pervasive
into Japanese culture too man I talked
to this one girl she's beautiful and
she's half Chinese half Japanese and I
had her on my show and we were
interviewing her
and I think she was like 19 or 20 at the
time I was like what's your plan she's
like well I'm just gonna date now and
then I'm gonna get married by the time
I'm 30. I'm like
okay like
how do you just know you're gonna get
married by 30.
right like it like first of all you have
to find someone second of all you have
to have some emotional compatibility
with that person and then third of all
your hope to have some sexual
compatibility and then fourth you would
hope that he would be faithful to you
and stay faithful to you only
like these people sit around and they
lie to themselves and they delude
themselves like oh like my you know what
they say I blame Disney right
what's the song yeah one day my Prince
Will Come no he's not coming he's not
coming well and even Denali yesterday
she's like you don't have to like like
the whole oh it'll come to you I'm like
no no no it won't no and that was that
was that was in my opinion with all due
respect or foolish and I told her about
that like did your YouTube success come
to you no did you Law of Attraction this
thing no no no no
no it was really hard it was really hard
and like honestly it was really
stressful really fast yeah and I don't
think a lot like that's the thing like a
lot of girls don't even know what
they're signing up for like it comes
with a lot of problems yeah and you you
have to like you have to endure through
the problems
I'll endure you know one day I'm gonna
get married and I will you better I I
will endure I'll find you yeah yeah I'll
find you I'll find you the champagne
bottle
yeah yeah I will
endure indoor will you endure I'm
enduring right now I'm an endurer i i
one of my favorite books I read in 2022
was Endure by Cameron Haynes have you
read that book I haven't but I I I
should read it because I want to endure
it it really teaches you how to endure
through hard times like during this
gigantic Cyber attack that I just had
from these this baseless viral
slandering campaign I had to endure
endure I've been doing right now
so I mean these people are just insane
they're insane uh King you wanna we'll
do part three guys we'll we'll try part
three tomorrow yes we will get through
this interview but thank you for coming
on today high five thanks for having me
on WE endured we how long has this been
like three hours I'm guessing it's a lot
of enduring and well it's a normal day
here we endure often we endure often
guys uh make sure you like the bit do we
hit our like our like what we wanted to
hit were we close I think we got to like
wonderful guys we were so close we got
1.3 000 likes you guys can hit one five
we're new one five um I think there was
a super chat that came in I'm gonna read
uh Pearl would your parents have an
issue with me having Joe Biden tattooed
on my middle finger yeah they would have
a big issue you know guys I grew up with
two conservative parents and you know my
personality is actually crazy liberal
like I'm like a like if I take a
personality test it says I have a 92
chance of being a liberal and the only
reason I wasn't is because every day I
would come home with a creative new idea
and my dad would just say no that's
stupid and tell me why it was stupid in
real time
um or or
um if it wasn't for him I would probably
be be probably be a hippie in like a van
somewhere yeah I used to want to live in
a van really yeah when I was younger
yeah I did it I sort of did it my
parents have a have a van so they have a
16 passenger van for me and my siblings
yeah and um growing up we would do road
trips in it and for a month I just was
like I'm gonna travel to like the US and
live in a van and I hated it I'm doing
like Walmart parking lot don't don't do
that yeah it's Common Sense strikes
through again yeah my dad was like why
don't you try it knowing you know he's
like why don't you just try this
lifestyle you wanted to watch you fail
yeah yeah my mom was like no don't
encourage this he's like oh no try it
see how this goes like when you let the
kids like let him touch the Hot Stuff
he'd be all right I keep running back I
was like Dad I'm at home okay guys like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel make sure you go subscribe
to mld's channel um what they just have
to put in Modern Life dating Modern Life
dating all one word or just click the
Modern Life dating tag in today's uh
Title Here in this video like the video
on your way out guys subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time
endure enjoy